Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pridlaff und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe 117 von,
ja, unserem Krisen-Podcast,
wie er sich so ein bisschen entwickelt,
hat in den letzten Jahren und heute soll es um die Ukraine gehen.
Ja wir wissen es gibt auch andere Krisen, der wir uns auch nochmal annehmen
wollen, aber heute haben wir so den Eindruck gehabt, wäre es ganz gut sich noch
ein weiteres Mal der Ukrainer zuzuwenden und das mache ich natürlich mit Pawel. Hallo Pawel.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, wir haben heute den 22. November 2023 und ja, gibt so einige Jubiläen,
die hier zusammenkommen.
Zu dem einen werden wir gleich noch kommen, nämlich am 21.
November 2013, also vor zehn Jahren ist diese Maidan-Revolution in der Ukraine losgegangen.
Dazu werden wir dann später nochmal diskutieren. Aber vielleicht vorher nochmal so ein eigener Sache.
Heute auch noch ein anderer Geburtstag, nämlich die Meta-Ebene ist volljährig geworden.
18 Jahre ist es her, dass ich den ersten Podcast veröffentlicht habe.
Das war natürlich kein UKW, sondern CRE.
Das ist quasi das Experiment, mit dem alles mal gestartet ist.
Damals hieß das ja noch Chaos Radio Express, weil es in gewisser Hinsicht ja
die Fortsetzung meiner Radioaktivität war.
Schönes Wort, ne? Fortsetzung meiner Radioaktivität, also ich strahle seitdem
sozusagen permanent ab.
Weil ich schon 10 Jahre davor, also tatsächlich im November 20, 2000,
nein 1900, oh Gott, damals,
im anderen Jahrtausend sozusagen, also 1995 ging das ja los mit Chaos Radio,
wo wir vom Chaos Computer Club aus halt da irgendwie einmal im Monat Sendung
gemacht haben, wo ich so ein bisschen auf den Geschmack gekommen bin.
Also in gewisser Hinsicht kann man sagen, bin ich eigentlich schon seit 28 Jahren
jetzt dabei, in irgendeiner Form zu senden und wollte das dann eben in Podcast-Form,
in eigener Regie machen und ja, insofern sind wir wahrscheinlich schon 28 Jahre,
aber jetzt sind 18 Jahre quasi rein Meta-Ebene zusammengekommen und ja, ich denke, das...
Könnte man mal erwähnen. Du bist ja auch Teil dieser Geschichte, Pawel.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Ich war ja auch irgendwie auch davor dabei, auch bei Chaos Radio,
bei der einen oder anderen Sendung auf Fritz.
Richtig.
Und ja, das war damals immer, da waren wir zu viert oder zu fünft im Studio
und dann gab es noch Nachrichten dazwischen und Werbeunterbrechungen.
Und mit fünf Leuten hatte man das Gefühl, dass jeder irgendwie so gerade mal
fünf bis zehn Minuten reden kann und man saß dann da trotzdem drei, vier Stunden so.
Und ich denke, da war der Podcast auch so ein Mittel, um irgendwie ein bisschen
mehr in die Tiefe gehen zu können.
Absolut, absolut. Das war definitiv so. Und du warst dann auch noch in weiteren
transformativen Momenten dabei.
Also unter anderem beim dritten Podcast, unsere Testsendung.
Das war nämlich das erste Mal, dass ich überhaupt mit jemand anderem was am Mikrofon gemacht habe.
Das erste Mal, wo ich quasi ein zweites Mikrofon benutzt habe.
Vorher war das mehr so ein Durchsagen-Podcast, das war halt ja am Anfang noch
alles, das war am Anfang halt Experiment.
Es war sozusagen ein, was mach ich hier eigentlich, jetzt muss ich erstmal gucken,
jetzt muss ich erstmal ein Format finden.
Und bei dieser Formatfindung warst du dann doch auf eine interessante Art und Weise immer mit dabei.
Die Testsendung war ja eher so ein Unfall, das war ja so, ich zeig dir mal das
Equipment und während wir da so sprachen, haben wir dann so mittendrin beschlossen
das einfach mal aufzunehmen und eine Sendung draus zu machen.
Deswegen war es halt eine Testsendung. Das war ganz interessant.
Aber noch eine andere Sendung war von uns ganz transformativ. Nämlich die 28. Folge.
Da haben wir uns über Programmiertechniken unterhalten.
Extreme Programming. Das war dann im Folgejahr, im Mai 2006 und ich weiß nicht,
ob du dich an diese Sendung noch erinnern kannst, aber die ist insofern besonders gewesen,
als dass eigentlich dort das erste Mal wirklich dieses Konzept des Interview-Podcasts.
Der dann CRI wurde, eigentlich das erste mal sich manifestiert hat.
Also ich hatte zwar auch schon vorher Sendungen, aber die waren dann sehr viel kürzer, 28 Minuten,
39 Minuten, also es war für meine heutigen Verhältnis sehr überschaubar und
ich würde sagen vom ganzen Vibe her und so weiter,
für mein Gefühl war das sozusagen die erste Sendung, kann man nicht drüber streiten.
Du meinst, ich habe die Länge reingebracht.
Du hast auf jeden Fall die Länge reingebracht. Das war das erste Mal,
dass es glaube ich über eine Stunde ging, wenn ich es richtig sehe.
Jetzt will ich nichts Falsches sagen.
Tatsächlich bin ich vorher, ja Stunde 17 gab es schon nochmal mit Harald Welte und so.
Also trotzdem, egal. Auf jeden Fall, ich erwähne die Sendung deshalb,
weil ich die jetzt auch gerade nochmal neu geschnitten habe,
weil ich hatte damals so ein bisschen die schlechte Angewohnheit Hintergrundmusik laufen zu lassen.
Das habe ich schwer bereut dann später und jetzt könnte ich halt mit aktueller Technik, KI sei Dank,
kann man ja sehr effizient, wie ich festgestellt habe,
diese Hintergrundmusik entfernen und trotzdem bleibt noch die Qualität der Sprache
erhalten und man merkt eigentlich gar nichts davon und habe sozusagen die Sendung
jetzt nochmal neu geschnitten und neu veröffentlicht und ja,
jetzt kann man sich das alles mal wieder anhören.
Na gut, so viel dazu.
Vielen Dank für alle, die hier die Meta-Ebene begleiten.
Ist ja auch ein interessanter Weg gewesen für mich, so als wirtschaftliche.
Entscheidung zu sagen, ich mag das so gerne, ich will jetzt eigentlich gar nichts
anderes mehr machen, ich hab zwar keine Ahnung, wie man das finanzieren kann,
aber ich mach das jetzt einfach mal.
Das war so ein bisschen meine Überzeugung, mit der ich da reingegangen bin,
dass ich mir dachte, wenn das toll ist, wenn das das ist, was ich gerne tun
will, dann muss das auch irgendwie funktionieren können.
Auch wenn ich noch nicht genau sagen kann, wie es funktioniert.
Und hab dann erstmal ein paar Jahre einfach so ins Blaue gesendet und mich eigentlich
damals komplett nur von meinen Reserven ernährt.
Und später nahm das dann so ein bisschen Fahrt auf, dass Leute gesagt haben,
du, wir wollen das auch gerne unterstützen, wie wärs?
Dass ich so gemerkt habe, okay, dieses Modell, das passt eigentlich wunderbar.
Weil natürlich alle anderen Überlegungen, sich irgendwie beauftragen zu lassen,
sich Sponsoren zu suchen oder Ware, sogar mit Werbung anzufangen,
das war für mich irgendwie alles nix.
Beziehungsweise die paar Kooperationen, die ich so in der Zeit gehabt habe,
die waren zwar alle ganz gut, aber das war dann am Ende auch eher anstrengender
als wirklich hilfreich.
Sodass ich dann sozusagen den Weg komplett in die Unabhängigkeit gesucht habe
und eigentlich auch gefunden habe, dadurch, dass ihr die Mittelebene alle so
unterstützt über die Zeit.
Ja.
Insofern vielen Dank dafür und wer Lust hat dafür zu sorgen,
dass die Metaebene auch weiterhin so sendet, kann das gerne tun, metaebene.me.
Ich habe alles aufgeführt, wie ihr das tun könnt und das wäre mir auf jeden Fall eine große Hilfe,
weil es immer mal wieder große Investitionen nach sich zieht,
wie derzeit zum Beispiel gerade, wo ich mein Studio komplett neu aufbaue und
das sind alles so die Momente,
wo diese regelmäßige Unterstützung, insbesondere die regelmäßige Unterstützung, sehr viel Wert ist.
Soviel zu den Hausmitteilungen. Kommen wir zum Kern des Geschäfts und wir wollen
euch natürlich wieder ein Update bieten über den Stand des Krieges in der Ukraine.
Ich finde irgendwie so Krieg, wie sollte man diesen Krieg eigentlich nennen?
Also es gibt ja verschiedenste Bezeichnungen. Krieg in der Ukraine,
Krieg gegen die Ukraine, Krieg...
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine.
Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine. Ich glaube das offizielle Wikipedia-Lemmata,
ist russo-ukrainischer Krieg.
Und das ist alles natürlich nicht ganz falsch, aber ich denke man darf nicht
aus dem Auge verlieren, wie es hier eigentlich dazu kam.
Auch dazu wollen wir später noch ein bisschen mehr sagen, aber wir fangen jetzt
glaube ich erstmal an mit dem Militär-Update, um einfach mal die Situation on,
the ground festzumachen.
Wie es hier so unsere Art ist. Ja was passiert? Also wir hatten letztes Mal zu euch gesprochen.
Wann war das nochmal? Ich gucke gerade nochmal nach. Die Sendung wurde veröffentlicht am 25.
Oktober, also das ist so ziemlich genau einen Monat her.
Und die Situation war grob gesagt die,
die Offensive, die die Ukraine gestartet hatte im Sommer kam ein wenig zum Liegen
und es gab aber auch neue Bewegungen einerseits in positiver Hinsicht,
weil die Ukraine gerade mit diesen Atacams Missiles ausgestattet worden ist
und es geschafft hat diese Kampfhubschrauber Bastionen zu bekämpfen.
Das hat definitiv nochmal eine Auswirkung gehabt, aber kam insofern zu spät für diese Offensive.
Ja, da war schon alles festgefahren zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Trotzdem ging das ja auch noch eine Weile so weiter mit diesen Luftschlägen,
mit diesen Atacams Missiles.
Mittlerweile sind also die Kampfhubschrauberstandorte, glaube ich,
auf russischen Boden verlegt worden, sodass also diese Kampfhubschrauber weniger
Zugriff haben auf die Grenze und den Frontverlauf insbesondere.
Das ist ganz positiv anzumerken. Trotzdem ist halt diese Gegenoffensive in dem
Sinne jetzt erstmal, ja, kann man jetzt nicht mehr von einer wirklichen Offensive sprechen.
Es gibt zwar dort an dieser Südfront weiterhin noch Kämpfe, die flammen insbesondere
immer dann auf, wenn die Russen sich zu sehr auf andere Bereiche konzentrieren.
Von daher kann jederzeit da nochmal irgendwas passieren, aber derzeit passiert
dort im Großen und Ganzen nicht viel.
In der Ukraine ist es gelungen nur, naja, ich weiß nicht wie viel Quadratkilometer
das sind, aber es ist alles sehr überschaubar, so unter 100 an Fläche,
die zurückgewonnen werden konnte. Das ist erstmal nicht viel.
Und das hat eben auch viel mit dem Mangel an Möglichkeiten zu tun,
gegen diese Minenfelder vorzugehen.
Die Hubschrauber waren halt ein Problem und natürlich ist permanent diese Artillerie
der Russen natürlich auch ein Problem.
So erfolgreich die Ukraine dagegen vorgehen kann teilweise, ist es halt einfach
insgesamt nicht genug. Denn die Russen, wir wissen das, machen immer alles mit
viel und schmeißen immer alles rein.
Egal, kostet was wolle. Menschenleben sind da ziemlich egal und es wird auch
einfach an Material alles verheizt, was da ist, weil einfach so viel da ist.
Weil einfach über Jahrzehnte Russland sich da solche Mengen zusammengebaut hat.
Wie lange das noch so gut geht, darüber können wir gerne auch nochmal diskutieren,
aber das ist sozusagen der Stand an dieser Front. Und was dann passiert ist,
ist, dass stattdessen die Russen wieder die Initiative übernommen haben.
Das ist insofern immer zu erwarten, wenn man sich den Verlauf des Krieges bisher
anschaut, dann war es immer so ein Hin und Her.
Es gab immer eine Seite hatte die Initiative, die andere musste darauf reagieren.
So lange bis das dann kulminiert ist und dann ist das Blatt wieder umgeschwenkt.
Wir haben das von Anfang an gehabt, der Angriff auf Kiew, der halt zurückgeschlagen
werden konnte, dann mussten sich die Russen zurückziehen.
Dann gab es den Angriff im Donbass, der dann auch durch die Offensive dann später
in Kharkiv beantwortet wurde.
Der Vorstoß in Kherson wurde dann eben auch zurückgeschlagen.
Also es schwankte immer so hin und her und jetzt haben wir wieder so einen Punkt
erreicht, wo es umschwenkt.
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer haben sich die Russen jetzt gerade mal wieder
in den Kopf gesetzt, sie bräuchten jetzt mal wieder so eine Art Erfolg,
den Putin vielleicht deshalb vorweisen möchte,
weil jetzt die Wahlen anstehen im nächsten Jahr und um diese Wahlen in irgendeiner
Form mit Erfolg zu kleiden, soll halt mal wieder irgendwas eingenommen werden,
dass man sagen kann, so hier haben wir mal wieder ein Battle.
Und ihr seht ja, es geht ja auch voran.
Und nachdem im letzten Jahr das halt sozusagen diese große Initiative war,
Ahmut einzunehmen, was ja am Ende auch...
Totalzerstörung der Stadt natürlich abgeschlossen werden konnte,
hat man sich jetzt offenbar auf Avdivka eingeschossen.
Und Avdivka ist ja eigentlich so eine Art Vorort, das ist überhaupt gar keine
größere Stadt, sondern mehr so ein Vorort von der Großstadt Donetsk,
also direkt vor den Türen der Stadt.
Und das ist so ein Bereich, den halt die Russen schon damals seit ihrem Vorstoß
2014 nie haben einnehmen können. Also das ist sehr gut zu verteidigen gewesen für die Ukraine.
Und jetzt haben also die Russen alles drauf geworfen.
Wir hatten es glaube ich in der letzten Sendung schon angedeutet,
dass diese Kämpfe begonnen haben und dass die Verluste der Russen da auch groß sind.
Also innerhalb von einer Woche hunderte von Fahrzeugen zerstört worden und tausende
von Soldaten und man denkt sich halt so, meine Güte, was soll das denn jetzt
schon wieder. Aber seitdem ging es halt die ganze Zeit so weiter.
Also der ganze letzte Monat war ein permanentes Anrollen der Russen auf Avdivka,
sowohl vom Norden als auch vom Süden und vom Südwesten.
Alles ist weitgehend zurückgeschlagen worden.
In diesem Monat haben sie zwar Fortschritte erzielt, im Sinne von,
dass sie ein paar Felder eingenommen haben, also ein paar hundert Meter oder
ein, zwei Kilometer in manchen Bereichen an Fläche haben, unter ihre Kontrolle bringen können.
Nur das mit den Verlusten ist so weitergegangen. Sie haben dann auch irgendwann
im Norden aufgehört mit Fahrzeugen vorzurücken.
Das hat damit zu tun, dass die Ukraine mittlerweile sehr gut darin zu sein scheint,
mit Electronic Warfare Equipment zu arbeiten.
Das heißt, sie sind in der Lage, die Drohnenaktivität der Russen weitgehend im Schach zu halten.
Damit fehlt sozusagen den Russen die Aufklärung. Auf der anderen Seite schaffen
sie es auch, ihre Drohnen relativ tief in das Angriffsgebiet der Russen einfallen zu lassen.
Man merkt richtig, wie die Ukraine voll auf diesen Drohnenkrieg setzt und das auch mit Erfolg.
Und das hat dann eben zur Folge, dass die Fahrzeuge, die dort im Norden von
Avdivka einen relativ langen Anfahrtsweg haben, weil da eigentlich nur so eine
Straße sich durchschlängelt, über die man wirklich diese ganzen Angriffe führen kann,
dass teilweise Fahrzeuge schon 10, 12 Kilometer hinter der eigentlichen Frontlinie
schon zerstört werden und überhaupt gar nicht so weit kommen.
Das hat dann wiederum zur Folge, dass die Russen ihre Taktik dahingehend geändert
haben, dass sie eigentlich nur noch mit Personal am Start sind.
Das heißt, wie man das schon in Mahmoud gesehen hat, Wellen von Infanterie,
die einfach vorgeschickt werden, das sind so diese Meatgrinder,
von denen immer wieder die Rede ist.
Also dass einfach die Leute quasi in die direkte Vernichtung getrieben werden.
Ja, einfach hier Leute, ihr geht jetzt mal an die Front, lauft mal nach vorne,
uns ist doch egal, was mit euch passiert.
Zu Tausenden kommen sie dort um, schaffen es dann aber halt irgendwann mal,
dann doch mal einen Graben zu nehmen und dann nochmal ein Feld zu überschreiten
und haben sich jetzt mittlerweile dort an dieser Eisenbahnlinie,
kurz vor diesem Chemiewerk, dem Kokswerk,
den Avdivka festgesetzt und werden halt dort zusammengeschossen.
Ja, also mein Avdivka ist,
glaube ich, im Gegensatz zu Bachmut, so ein bisschen unklar war oder wo die
Bedeutung von Bachmut eher symbolisch war,
ist Avdivka schon auch sowas wie ein Stachel einfach in der Front und droht
einfach aus russischer Sicht die Stadt Donetsk und den Flughafen südlich.
Der ist dadurch nicht benutzbar.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die Motivation auch groß ist, dieses Loch zu stopfen,
um eventuell auch
einen Vormarsch auf Donetsk irgendwann nicht so leicht zu riskieren oder zu
erschweren und die ukrainische Artillerie weiter von Donetsk wegzudrängen.
Insofern kann man das einerseits verstehen, das macht Sinn.
Aber was weniger Sinn macht, ist der irrsinnige Aufwand oder die Verluste.
Es geht wahrscheinlich mittlerweile weit über 10.000 verwundete und getötete Soldaten.
Die nicht mehr kämpfen können und sollen wohl um die 40.000 Soldaten zusammengezogen
haben für den Angriff auf Avdivka.
Also das ist schon eine größere Geschichte.
Und ja, mit aber sehr fragwürdigem Erfolg.
Also die Russen haben dieselben Probleme wie die Ukrainer, wenn es an die Offensive geht.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass die Ukrainer, nachdem sie gesehen haben,
dass das so verlustreich ist, sehr schnell umgestellt haben,
während die Russen doch einfach weitermachen und Verluste vor allem an Menschen
und Soldaten scheinbar nicht so wichtig zu sein scheinen bzw.
Durch den Einsatz der Storm-Z-Truppen.
Da
Wird das vermutlich von der russischen Führung als Win-Win gesehen.
Wenn sie es schaffen, der Ukraine Verluste zuzufügen, super.
Und selbst wenn sie es nicht schaffen, so bei den Strafgefangenen,
dann spart halt Russland an den Kosten, um die weiter im Gefängnis unterzubringen.
Also aus russischer Sicht, zynisch gesehen, egal, also egal, ob,
diese Storm-Z-Truppen Erfolg,
haben oder nicht, ist dann nicht zum Nachteil der Truppen.
Aber die Panzer, obwohl sie da auch am Anfang extrem viel verloren haben,
wie schon gesagt, sind sie dann jetzt dazu übergegangen, die Panzer zu schonen
und dafür mehr Menschen vorzuschicken,
die natürlich nicht so begeistert davon sind, was dann auch zu,
sagen auch Ständen, aber Weigeruppen geführt hat, einfach bei bestimmten russischen
Truppen diese Angriffe durchzuführen, die dann wiederum in irgendwelche Löcher
gesteckt wurden zur Bestrafung.
A. Da gibt es wirklich ganz furchtbare Videoberichte, wie mit diesen Leuten umgegangen wird.
Das ist einfach alles nur noch mit Polter gleichzusetzen und die Praxis,
dass Truppen quasi hinter der Frontlinie zu positionieren, die halt ganz klar
da stehen mit dem Auftrag, wenn irgendeiner,
der da gerade nach vorne geschickt wurde, einfach wieder zurückkehrt,
dann wird er einfach auch gleich erschossen.
Das wird ja auch schon seit längerem berichtet. Also das ist wirklich alles
nicht schön auf der russischen Seite.
Ich vermute mal nicht, dass das im großen Umfang und flächendeckend diese Barrier
Troops eingesetzt werden, aber es gab definitiv solche Vorkommnisse.
Also so geht es da halt in Avdivka zu und wenn sie dort 40.000 Truppen haben
und in Anführungsstrichen erst 10.000 davon verbraten haben,
kann man davon ausgehen, dass es noch weiter geht.
Das Ganze wird jetzt ohnehin noch erschwert dadurch, dass jetzt die Schnee und
Regensaison eingesetzt hat.
Also das ist diese, wie heißt das so schön, Rasputitsa.
Rasputitsa, genau. Das ist glaube ich der russische Name. Es gibt glaube ich
noch einen ukrainischen Namen dafür. Auf jeden Fall.
Das ist halt der Ort Usus. Das haben wir ja auch schon mehrfach berichtet.
So begann ja dieser Krieg im Prinzip auch schon.
Jetzt gibt es halt so eine Übergangsphase, bis es dann eben wirklich von den
Temperaturen wieder so ist, dass man unter Null landet und dann der Boden einfriert.
Dann sind halt auch wieder Bewegungen mit mechanisierten Truppen möglich.
Aber jetzt wird sich das alles erstmal im Wesentlichen als Infanterie- und Drohnenkrieg weiterentwickeln.
Und wie schon erwähnt, das mit den Drohnen hat zumindest für die Ukraine eine besondere Bedeutung.
Ukraine kann jetzt hier eigentlich nur gewinnen, weil sie in der Verteidigungsposition
sind und natürlich den Russen sehr viel größere Verluste zufügt,
als sie selber haben, aber das heißt nicht, dass sie keine hätten.
Ja, ich meine, wenn man das jetzt für den gesamten Kriegsverlauf sieht bisher,
scheint es so zu sein, wir haben keine guten Zahlen für ukrainische Verluste
und auch bei den russischen ist es schwierig,
aber es scheint so größenordnungsmäßig ungefähr 2 zu 1 zu sein,
dass die Russen also doppelt so viele Soldaten verloren haben wie die Ukrainer
und das wäre kein gutes Verhältnis für die Ukraine.
Die Ukraine müsste eigentlich mindestens so 3 zu 1 oder besser um mit der Sowjetunion
bevölkerungsmäßig mithalten zu können und 4 zu 1 oder höher um das bis zum Ende
durchkämpfen zu können.
Aber bei den momentanen Verlusten so, ja, die Russen haben deutlich höhere Verluste,
aber die Ukrainer eben leider auch so, auch wenn in geringerem Umfang.
Aber die Ukraine ist halt nun auch kleiner und kann sich auch einfach nicht
so viele Verluste leisten,
abgesehen davon, dass es eben auch eine Demokratie ist und die Leute dort mehr
zu sagen haben und sich auch nicht einfach so opfern lassen.
Ja, ich meine, das wissen natürlich auch die Ukrainer und die setzen halt sehr auf Technik.
Ich habe es ja schon erwähnt. Also die ukrainische Drohnen Armee ist ja auch
schon als solche benannt. Also die Army of Drones.
Sie haben eine enorme Schaffungsquote von so kommerziell verfügbaren Drohnen zur Aufklärung.
DJI und solche gab mal das Gerücht, dass sie irgendwie 60 Prozent der Jahresproduktion
von DJI aufkaufen, das ist aber unbestätigt, bzw.
Wurde von DJI sogar dementiert, weil sie keine Zahlen darüber rausgeben wie
viel sie verkaufen, von daher wollten sie da überhaupt gar nicht erst in den Vergleich kommen bzw.
Als chinesisches Unternehmen vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt in dieser ganzen
Debatte auftauchen, das kann natürlich auch sein.
Andererseits werden auch weitere Drohnensysteme, also die jetzt nicht fliegende
Drohnen gebaut, also automatisiert.
Minenleger Systeme gibt es. Es gibt glaube ich auch schon erste Experimente
für Demining, wobei das relativ schwierig ist.
Die Russen probieren es ähnlich, aber das ist dann mehr so, ja wenn wir jetzt
hier einen alten Panzer, den wir jetzt eh nicht mehr benutzen wollen,
füllen den mal mit Explosive und lassen den einfach auf die Frontlinie zu rollen.
Das war bisher aber nicht so erfolgreich glaube ich, weil die dann meistens auf den Minen laufen.
Aber da ist einiges zu erwarten und was wir ja auch schon erwähnt haben und
was man eigentlich ja immer wieder nur noch betonen kann ist ja,
dass die Ukraine es jetzt geschafft hat mit ihren automatisierten Booten im
Prinzip und natürlich auch mit den Storm Shadow Missiles und ihren sonstigen
Drohnen die Schwarzmeerflotte der Russen eigentlich komplett auszunommen.
Also das ist in der ganzen Darstellung des Krieges bei mir in meiner Wahrnehmung
vollkommen unterrepräsentiert, dass die Ukraine es aus eigener Kraft geschafft
hat, ohne eine Navy zu haben,
die russische Navy mehr oder weniger aus dem Spiel rauszunehmen.
Es sind mittlerweile schon über 100 zivile
Frachter von Odessa über die Schmarzmeerroute bis Istanbul gekommen.
Die fahren halt nicht mehr direkt übers Meer, sondern jetzt sehr nah am Ufer
entlang, an der rumänischen und an der bulgarischen Küste.
Das ist klar, aber sie finden den Weg und auch wenn es etwas aufwändiger und
teurer und noch seltener ist, als es das vorher war,
findet eine Delivery der Agrarprodukte der Ukraine in den Rest der Welt statt
und das bedeutet natürlich auch Einnahmen.
Es wurde auch beschlossen, die Versicherungen für die Frachter zu subventionieren,
weil die Versicherungen halt teurer sind oder extrem teuer sind,
wenn die diese Route fahren und da hat sich die Ukraine bereit erklärt,
die Mehrkosten für die Versicherung zu übernehmen.
Also auf jeden Fall ist der Ukrainer auch da gelungen den Druck der Russen rauszunehmen
an der Stelle, aber jetzt gibt es natürlich noch ein anderes interessantes militärisches Teilgebiet.
Das hatten wir glaube ich auch in der letzten Sendung schon kurz angesprochen, dass sich da was tut.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt war aber noch nicht so ganz klar, welche Bedeutung das hat.
Das ist halt das Gebiet ganz im Westen bei der Stadt Resson, also Nipro-Ufer.
Wir reden jetzt speziell von dem Bereich von Novokorkovka. Das ist da,
wo der mittlerweile gesprengte Nipro-Damm.
Staudamm war, der dieses ganze Becken ja aufgestaut hat. Der ist ja jetzt weg.
Ich habe jetzt immer noch keine aktuellen Satellitenbilder mal gesehen von diesem
Nipro-Becken, wie das jetzt eigentlich aussieht.
Aber es dürfte sich im Wesentlichen auf den ursprünglichen Flussverlauf zurückgezogen.
Aber das ist eine einzige Schlammwüste, da kann man also noch nicht in irgendeiner
Form rüberfahren oder so.
Mal gucken, wie sich das noch so entwickelt im Verlauf des Kriegs,
das könnte nochmal ganz interessant werden. Aber davon abgesehen...
Der gesamte restliche Flusslauf, also von Nowakowkowka, wo der Abstand zwischen
den beiden Ufern überschaubar ist,
dort erstreckt sich jetzt eine neue Frontlinie,
die die Ukrainer aufgemacht haben, indem sie in der letzten Zeit gezielt mit
speziellen Einsatztruppen übergesetzt haben, in kleinen Booten und einzelne
Brückenköpfe aufgebaut haben.
Das ging los vor zwei Monaten war das glaube ich mit dem Brückenkopf unter der
alten Gespreng-Antonowsky-Brücke.
Das ist diese große Autobahnbrücke, die die Russen gesprengt haben bei ihrem Rückzug.
Da gab es eine Stelle, wo man quasi so einen natürlichen Bunker hatte.
Dort haben sich dann die Ukrainer eingenistet und den Russen ist es nicht gelungen, sie dort zu vertreiben.
Aber mit der Zeit, die ukrainischen Spezialtruppen dann noch so zwei,
drei, vier andere Orte gefunden, wo sie übergesetzt haben und sozusagen Stück
für Stück eine Infrastruktur aufgebaut haben.
Für so einen Angriff muss man ja mal bedenken, es reicht ja nicht einfach rüber
zu fahren und loszuballern, sondern jeder Soldat, der dort zum Einsatz kommt,
der muss ja auch versorgt werden. Also Essen muss geliefert werden.
Man braucht Schutz natürlich. Man muss eine Waffen-Munitionsversorgung.
Sicher stellen. Und natürlich braucht man auch Medical Support,
die werden dann verletzt oder werden sonst irgendwie krank und müssen ja dann
auch wieder eine Chance haben entweder sofort behandelt zu werden bzw.
Rückgeführt zu werden und dann brauchst du einfach auch eine Truppenrotation.
Weil einfach die Leute nicht dauerhaft dort bleiben können.
Bei den Russen ist das ja normal, aber in der Ukraine wird dafür gesorgt,
dass diese Truppen möglichst schnell durchrotiert werden, damit die immer wieder
die Möglichkeit haben, sich von dem ganzen Stress zu erholen,
soweit das eben in so einem Krieg überhaupt möglich ist.
Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob die Russen diese Situation unterschätzt haben oder
nur von Anfang an einfach Schwierigkeiten hatten, dagegen vorzugehen,
aber in den letzten Wochen ist diese Präsenz an diesen einzelnen Übertrittsorten so stark geworden,
dass mittlerweile die Ukraine hier wirklich in eine Mini-Offensive übergegangen ist.
Und das ist gerade deshalb für die Russen so ein Problem, weil erstens ist das
halt alles eine sehr dünn besiedelte Region, wo auch so größere Wüstengebiete sind.
Da führt dann von Osten nach Westen nur eine einzige große Straße und das ist
natürlich dann für die Ukrainer einfacher hier durch die Wälder zu ziehen und
diese Straße in Bedrohung zu nehmen,
was dann eben die ganze Versorgung der restlichen Truppen nochmal extrem gefährdet.
Und jetzt gibt es also diverse Kämpfe, die hier entbrannt sind und es macht
gerade so den Eindruck, als ob es der Ukraine gelingen könnte,
diese Orte dauerhaft zu besetzen und vielleicht, wenn alles richtig gut läuft,
vielleicht sogar die Russen in diesem Gebiet ein bisschen zurückzudrängen.
Taktisch sieht es ja so aus, das hat man ja auch erwähnt, dass ja von dem höheren rechten Dniepro-Ufer,
die ukrainischen,
Truppen per Artillerie und auch Drohnen unterstützt werden.
Die Frage ist, wie geht das dann weiter?
Also das Problem ist, wenn sie dann jetzt mit einer größeren Truppenpräsenz
dort ihren Brückenkopf verstärken,
die Ukraine, und die Russen sich dann zurückziehen, dann haben sie irgendwann
nicht mehr die Deckung durch die eigene Artillerie,
die Ukrainer, und sind dann quasi in einem Gebiet, wo sie dann wiederum auch
noch mehr der russischen Artillerie ausgesetzt sind.
Und insbesondere natürlich die Versorgungswege.
Insofern wird es interessant zu beobachten sein.
Und die Russen nehmen das schon ein bisschen ernst und haben ja den Kommandeur
ausgewechselt gegen einen Neuen, der dann explizit den Auftrag hatte,
jetzt die zu vertreiben,
ist ihm aber jetzt in den,
das war vor einem Monat, glaube ich, und ist ihm jetzt auch nicht besser gelungen,
als seinem Vorgänger dort die Situation in den Griff zu kriegen.
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Also klar, es wird vielleicht erstmal etwas schwierig
sein, für die Ukraine eine vorgerückte Position weiter auszubauen,
aber würden sie zumindest diesen Streifen, diesen ganzen Küsten-Ufer-Streifen des,
Nibiru wieder unter ihre Kontrolle bekommen? Und das würde ja dann auch die
entlegeneren Gebiete hinten an diesen Kinburnspit, also da wo der Nipro ins
Schwarze Meer fließt, wenn sie das sozusagen alles wieder unter ihre Kontrolle bekommen,
dann können sie natürlich auch mit Fähren sehr viel einfacher größeres Material
rüberbringen und Schritt für Schritt sich dort eben auch etwas aufbauen.
Ich glaube, dass gerade diese dünn besiedelten Westgebiete da ganz interessant
sein könnten, weil wenn die Russen sich zurückziehen, dann werden sie dort noch
nicht mal erst mal mit Artillerie hinkommen können.
Und die Orte zurückzugewinnen ist natürlich auf jeden Fall auch schon mal gut.
Genauso geht es, wenn sie die Kontrolle zum Beispiel über Nowak-Karkowka bekommen
könnten, also direkt an diesem ehemaligen Staudamm, einfach auch mal dort so
ein Assessment machen zu können, was da jetzt eigentlich wirklich passiert ist,
das ist derzeit ja alles noch viel zu gefährlich.
Glaube ich schon, dass sie dann eine ganze Menge Druck ausüben können.
Ihre Artillerie reicht ja ohnehin weiter als die der Russen und ja diese ganzen
Drohnen Systeme scheinen ja sehr effizient zu sein.
Die Elektronik-Warfare Systeme, die sie dort am Start haben,
scheinen auch sehr effizient zu sein.
Es gibt neue Drohnen mit stärkeren Antennen, die gegen diese IW-Systeme der,
Russen offenbar auch weniger anfällig sind.
Also das ist auch ein technologischer Krieg an dieser Stelle,
aber es wäre natürlich vor allem für die Ukraine auch ein wichtiger moralischer
Sieg hier in irgendeiner Form mal wieder die ganze Stellung weitern zu können,
denn machen wir uns nichts vor.
Seit einem Jahr haben wir im Prinzip denselben Frontverlauf,
der hat sich nur sehr gering geändert und das wäre jetzt hier der erste wirklich
nennenswerte Fortschritt, der in diesen ganzen zwölf Monaten erzielt werden konnte.
Ja,
nur dass sich dann grundsätzlich die Ukrainer in derselben Situation wiederfinden
könnten oder in einer ähnlichen Situation, wie damals die Russen auf der anderen Seite,
waren, nämlich dass die Versorgung dann über den Fluss,
über wenige Brücken erfolgt ist, die dann relativ einfach zu bekämpfen oder
zu zu stören sind, weil man dann halt weiß, wo das ist, so mit anderen Worten.
Also wird wird dann auch nicht einfach werden, selbst wenn es gelingt,
dort die Brückenköpfe auszubauen und zu festigen.
Schon sagt es, die dann die dann weiter vorzuschieben. Aber es wäre auf jeden
Fall ein Erfolg und würde dazu führen,
dass die Russen dann wiederum Truppen von anderen Fronten abziehen müssen,
um dort die Front zu halten.
Also insofern würde es sich allein deswegen wahrscheinlich schon lohnen,
für die Ukraine das zu tun.
Ja, einfach ist ja sowieso nichts in diesem Krieg. Insofern wäre das auf jeden
Fall mal eine neue Bewegung.
Und ich glaube, das wäre auch wieder einmal ein wichtiges Signal an die internationale
Gemeinschaft, dass hier sehr wohl Fortschritte erzielt werden können,
solange die Ukraine nur korrekt ausgestattet wird.
Aber dazu kommen wir auch nochmal. BK'IN DR.
WERBER Ja, aber vielleicht noch zuzufügen, dass die Russen an verschiedenen
Stellen eben militärisch auch aufgeholt haben,
selber auch mehr Drohnen zum Einsatz bringen jetzt,
also sich auch entsprechend angepasst haben und sich in Teilen bei den Ukrainern
viele Dinge auch abgeguckt haben, die sie jetzt dann selbst machen,
eben wie dann auch mit Drohnen, viel mit Kamikaze-Drohnen auch zu arbeiten.
Und die elektronische Kampfführung auch der Russen ist ein bisschen besser geworden,
Aber das Problem dort scheint zu sein,
dass sie sich nicht gut koordinieren untereinander jetzt die russischen Truppen
und oft einen Kompromiss machen müssen,
weil sie sich dann selber stören, also weil sie dann auch die eigene Kommunikation
und die eigenen Drohnen zum Teil nicht funktionieren.
Das ist wohl gerade das Problem, dass sie tendenziell...
Schon mit elektronischer Kampfführung mehr gegen die Drohnen unternehmen können.
Also grundsätzlich funktioniert das, gerade gegenüber den kommerziellen Drohnen,
aber selbst auch militärischen Drohnen nur,
ja, stören sie dann eben auch die eigenen Drohnen, weshalb sie das jetzt nicht
einfach flächendeckend einsetzen können und sich eben oft auch gegenseitig stören.
Ich meine, am Anfang war es schlimmer. Bei dem Angriff auf Kiew wurde dann ja
befohlen, dass grundsätzlich alle ihre Geräte abstellen mussten,
weil die russische Kommunikation dann auch komplett zusammengebrochen war.
Und da sind sie jetzt ein bisschen besser geworden, was das angeht und ja,
holen ein bisschen auf, kann man sagen, an verschiedenen Stellen.
BG'IN Ja, um den militärischen Ausblick abzuschließen, erstmal,
was halt jetzt auf jeden Fall ansteht und was ich auch schon abzeichne,
sind natürlich jetzt wieder neue Langstrecken-Raketenangriffe,
auf den Rest des ukrainischen Landes.
Das haben wir ja im letzten Winter schon gesehen, dass die Russen versucht haben
insbesondere die Energieinfrastruktur zu zerstören.
Also Heißkraftwerke, Stromkraftwerke, Stromverteilerstationen insbesondere,
die besonders anfällig sind, weil sie auf der einen Seite nicht gut geschützt
sind, auf der anderen Seite, wenn sie kaputt sind, auch sehr schwer zu ersetzen
sind, weil einfach diese Geräte so nicht verfügbar sind und auch teuer.
Da ist einiges geflickt worden, aber insgesamt ist die Infrastruktur,
die jetzt noch da ist, sehr viel anfälliger gegenüber weiteren Zerstörungen,
weil dann wird es halt auch kritisch und noch schwieriger, das zu reparieren.
Dementsprechend ist die Luftabwehr weiter verstärkt worden.
Kiew, auch wenn immer mal wieder Raketen durchkommen, dürfte mittlerweile schon
ziemlich gut geschützt sein.
Es gab ja diverse neue Lieferungen von Luftabwehrsystemen aus allen möglichen Ländern.
Schwedische Systeme, amerikanische Systeme, deutsche Systeme.
Deutschen haben jetzt auch gerade noch mal neue IRIS-T Systeme zugesagt.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall hilfreich, aber es wird eben nicht ausreichen.
Es geht so die Kunde rum, dass die Russen es geschafft haben,
ihre Raketenproduktion, insbesondere von diesen Iskander Raketen, kräftig hochzufahren.
Ich habe jetzt gerade keine Zahl im Kopf, was da so die herumfliegenden Einschätzungen
waren, wie viel sie da produzieren können pro Monat, aber auf jeden Fall genug,
um ordentlich Ärger zu machen.
Da muss also die Abschussquote schon sehr hoch sein, damit das keine Probleme
erzeugt und außerdem geht die Unterstützung des Iran weiter,
also abgesehen von diesen einfachen, normal motorisierten Shahed Drohnen,
die schon eine ganze Menge Ärger gemacht haben, wenngleich sie mit so einem
Gepard oder so ganz gut abgeschossen werden können, aber auch da kommen immer wieder welche durch.
Da gibt es einerseits eine neue Version von, die jetzt wohl mit Jet-Fuel läuft,
die dann vielleicht nicht so viel Reichweite hat, aber die dann.
Schneller unterwegs sind und schwieriger abzuschießen sind und es geht jetzt
auch die Kunde, dass der Iran auch da drauf und dran ist, den Russen ihre Langstrecken-Raketen,
zu verkaufen und das könnte auch nochmal richtig negative Auswirkungen haben.
Überhaupt ist diese ganze Achse Iran-Russland hochproblematisch und sehr bedenklich,
und das ist vor allem im Bereich der Militärtechnologie halt so ein Ding,
weil die Russen jetzt auch gerade dabei sind quasi ihr Know-How zu verkaufen,
auch nach Nordkorea und dann eben auch in den Iran.
So nach dem Motto hier, wir können einige Sachen sehr gut, das zeigen wir euch
oder liefern euch vielleicht auch irgendwas, was wir gerade selber nicht brauchen,
aber ich glaube da geht es im Wesentlichen um Know-How.
Und dafür gibt es dann eben die Möglichkeit, ordentlich Kriegsgerät, Munition etc.
Einzukaufen, um die Bestände der Russen dort aufzustocken.
Also ich habe so Zahlen gehört, zwischen 100 und 300 Cruise Missiles oder ballistische,
Kurzstreckenraketen pro Monat, die die Russen in der Lage sind zu produzieren,
also es ist so Iskander-Systeme.
Was schon eine Menge ist. Also im Vergleich zu dem, was die Ukraine aus dem
Westen geliefert kriegt jetzt an Attackers oder eben an anderen Russ Missiles,
ja, da können die Russen durchaus gegenhalten, beziehungsweise haben wahrscheinlich
deutlich, deutlich mehr.
Plus dann eben diese billigen Schahid-Drohnen, die Russland jetzt ja auch selber produziert.
Also da ist durchaus auch eine ganze Menge.
Wobei die Ukraine entsprechend dem auch entgegensetzt und auch selbst produziert.
Aber ich würde davon ausgehen, dass die Russen wahrscheinlich irgendwie 10 bis
50 mal so viele Eigenproduktionen haben wie die Ukraine.
Und vielleicht, weiß nicht, das 5 bis 10 fache von dem, was die Ukraine aus
dem Westen geliefert bekommt an jetzt Langstreckenraketen und Cruise Missiles.
So, das ist leider so.
Also soviel vielleicht so zum militärischen, was sich gerade für uns so darstellt.
In anderen Worten, im Großen und Ganzen fährt sich hier alles gegenseitig ein bisschen ein.
Jetzt gibt es ein bisschen Pause durch die Wetterverhältnisse,
aber die Kämpfe gehen eigentlich die ganze Zeit weiter.
Es ist bloß nicht mit größeren Geländegewinnen zu rechnen in absehbarer Zeit.
Und es hat sich so entwickelt, wie wir das auch in den letzten Sendungen,
oder mindestens, du warst ja etwas optimistischer, was die Offensive angeht, so mein Problem war ja,
dass du als Angreifer eine größere Übermacht brauchst, um erfolgreich zu sein
und dass Im Moment sind beide Seiten nicht in der Lage,
diese notwendige Übermacht tatsächlich aufzubringen.
Damit Russland jetzt wirklich den Krieg gewinnen könnte, müssten sie wahrscheinlich
in der Größenordnung zwischen anderthalb und zweieinhalb Millionen Soldaten mobilisieren.
Mit den 400.000 werden sie einfach nicht weit kommen.
Und wieviel die Ukraine hat an Soldaten,
ja wahrscheinlich irgendwo 600.000 bis 800.000,
dürfte die Ukraine unter Waffen haben und das reicht aber auch wiederum nicht
aus, wie wir jetzt gesehen haben im Sommer bisher, um die Russen aus dem Land
zu vertreiben und eine schnelle Änderung ist nicht absehbar.
Gut, dann lasst uns mal den anderen Geburtstag leuchten, den ich vorhin schon
angedeutet habe, nämlich 10 Jahre Maidan oder 10 Jahre Euro-Maidan, um genauer zu sein.
Weil das ist so ein bisschen auch, sagen wir mal so ein bisschen der entscheidende
Vorgang gewesen und ich muss zugeben,
als ich mir damals die Ereignisse in Kiew aus der Ferne angeschaut habe,
war ich mit viel Fragezeichen ausgestattet und glaube so ging es den meisten
und so geht es wahrscheinlich auch heute noch den meisten,
was so die ganzen politischen Zusammenhänge betrifft, aber ich konnte das damals
nicht so richtig einordnen.
Okay, man kannte das aus den verschiedenen Revolutionen nach dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion,
dass halt in einzelnen osteuropäischen Ländern es Konflikte gab,
die vor allem nach außen immer so ein bisschen aussahen wie innenpolitische Konflikte.
Alle politischen Player, die damals so in der Ukraine kannt waren,
hatten halt irgendwie auch alle irgendwie Dreck am Stecken und egal,
wer mal für eine kurze Zeit irgendwie eine Regierung übernommen hat,
es hat immer nicht lange gedauert,
bis alle in so einem Korruptionssumpf wieder verreckt sind und man immer so
diesen Eindruck gewonnen hat, es ist eigentlich eh egal, wer da jetzt irgendwas macht.
Das ändert sich so schnell und das sind Dinge, die wir nicht verstehen und das
sind Dinge, auf die wir keinen Einfluss haben.
Und wer versteht das schon alles da mit diesen ehemaligen Sowjetrepubliken,
das ist uns alles zu kompliziert.
Ich meine, wir verstehen ja schon Polen nicht so und das grenzt ja wirklich
unmittelbar in der Nähe von Berlin an uns.
Und mit Tschechien ist es ja nicht sehr viel anders.
Und insofern war die Ukraine dann eben auch noch mal besonders weit weg. Aber was ist passiert?
Es gab dort halt einfach Aufstände, ausgelöst durch den Präsident Janukowitsch,
der halt als extrem russlandfreundlich galt und das auch war.
Und das eskalierte alles in Protesten, die dann eben auf diesem großen Platz
in Kiew, dem Maidan, sich zusammenfanden.
Und aus diesen Demonstrationen ist dann halt eine richtige Schlacht geworden,
weil natürlich das Regime versucht hat, diese Proteste zu unterdrücken.
Und dort gab es also dann auch Waffeneinsatz, sind Leute ums Leben gekommen.
Die Proteste haben monatelang angehalten. Das lief dann halt vom 21.
November bis in den Februar des nächsten Jahres rein,
bis das ganze dann eben in der Flucht, also der Absetzung und der Flucht des
Präsidenten Jenukowitsch gipfelte und damit sozusagen der Stadthalter Russlands
in der Ukraine fliehen musste.
Es gab dann schöne Bilder von seinen Palästen, die er dahinter gelassen hat.
Das Übliche, was man so kennt, wenn es sich die Leute zu gut gehen lassen mit ihrem Machteinfluss.
Es hieß ja immer Euro Maidan, weil diese Proteste waren eben nicht nur Proteste
gegen diesen Präsidenten,
sondern es waren halt auf der einen Seite auch Proteste gegen Russland,
gegen den russischen Einfluss und es waren auch Proteste für eine Integration
der Ukraine in Europa, Vor allem die Europäische Union in die westliche Demokratiewelt.
Ich glaube, dass ist so teilweise korruptiert worden, auch teilweise verstanden worden.
Aber ich glaube keiner konnte so richtig erahnen, wie tief dieser Wunsch wirklich
in der ukrainischen Gesellschaft so verankert war.
Und danach kam ja im Prinzip auch sofort die Antwort Russlands.
Denn im März, also einen Monat nachdem diese Proteste dann beendet waren am Maidan,
im März gab es diese Annexion der Krim,
wo Russland einfach sneaky sneaky mit so reingeschmuggelten Militärtruppen in
der Krim einfach auf einmal überall präsent war und quasi der Ukraine einfach
das Land entrissen hat, ohne dass es zu größeren Kämpfen kam.
Also rein militärtaktisch natürlich irgendwie ein großer Wurf,
aber es ist halt auch so gewesen, dass die Russen dort schon immer eine Präsenz
hatten, weil der Hafen von Sevastopol war ja schon immer der russische Militärhafen
auf ukrainischem Gebiet,
auf Vertragsbasis, so ein bisschen wie Guantanamo irgendwie in Kuba existiert
und von daher ja, hat einfach Untertitel der Amara.org-Community.
Russland da die Ukraine auf dem linken Fuß erwischt und sie war zu dem Zeitpunkt
ja auch militärisch nicht so viel in der Lage und das hat sich dort ja auch gezeigt.
Und einen Monat später wiederum schon im April 2014 gab es dann eben auch diese
Aufstände oder Angriffe kann man sagen in Donbass.
Getarnt als Widerstände, Widerstandskämpfer etc.
Freiheitskämpfer des Donbass.
Aber damit begann im Prinzip dieser Krieg zwischen Russland und der Ukraine,
also in militärischer Ausprägung.
Und das ist eigentlich das, was uns bis heute noch verfolgt.
Lange, lange Zeit wurde dann dieser Krieg so als solcher gar nicht so gesehen.
Das war halt irgendwie ja Widerstand im Krieg im Donbass, aber was haben wir
damit zu tun? Das ist ja so ein ukrainisch-russisches Sing, so Sowjetrepubliken,
unter sich. Das können wir da schon groß tun.
Ja und dann haben wir da eben das alles lange, lange, lange Zeit ignoriert.
Gut, es gab politische Versuche von Angela Merkel und anderen Führern dort in
irgendeiner Form für Frieden zu sorgen.
Aber das haben wir ja auch gesehen, wie gut das funktioniert hat.
Es gab dann halt diese, wie ist das Memorandum noch gleich?
Es gab das Minsker Abkommen oder zwei Minsker Abkommen, wo sozusagen ein Scheinfrieden
ausgehandelt wurde zwischen Russland und der Ukraine, den Russland dann am Ende nicht eingehalten hat.
Und trotz der Protektion durch die USA und Großbritannien kam es dann trotzdem zu diesem Krieg.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Sichtweise, wobei ich würde,
also die Russen sehen das natürlich alles ganz, ganz anders und letztlich,
ja, damals die Situation war ja, dass die Ukraine einfach und massiv unter dem
Einfluss Russlands stand,
so ich meine da gab es enorme wirtschaftliche Verflechtungen natürlich,
plus das, um die Ukraine bei Laune zu halten, hat Russland dann auch verbilligt
Gas geliefert und so also...
Ja, es war schon eng verflochten und los ging das eigentlich damit,
dass die NATO die Einladung an die Ukraine ausgesprochen hat damals oder eine Aussicht gestellt hat,
dass die Ukraine NATO-Mitglied werden könnte und die EU auch entsprechend Avancen gemacht hat.
Das kann man jetzt nicht nur kritisieren, das wird von vielen auch kritisiert,
dass quasi dadurch jetzt der Westen das Ganze mehr oder weniger provoziert hat.
Aber gut, die Avancen waren nun mal da und die hätten aber nicht funktioniert.
Ich meine, Finnland ist 50 Jahre lang kein NATO-Mitglied geworden.
Oder andere Länder auch nicht, obwohl sie es hätten werden können,
wenn nicht gleichzeitig die Situation in der Ukraine, wie du schon sagtest,
auch mit unglaublicher Korruption, persönliche Bereicherung,
die Wirtschaft lief schlecht und dann auch noch Wahlbetrugsvorwürfe und so.
Und deswegen war dann einfach in dieser wirtschaftlich schlechten Situation die Aussicht.
Sich an den Westen, also offensichtlich mit Russland, trotz billigen Gases und
der wirtschaftlichen Verflechtung.
Und so ging es den Leuten einfach nicht gut.
Und deswegen war dann die Orientierung nach Westen natürlich auch einfach attraktiv für die Leute.
Und dann war es eben auch so,
dass nachdem jetzt die neue ukrainische Regierung begonnen hatte,
sich an die EU anzunähern, hat Russland dann noch mal ein Paket draufgelegt,
quasi mit wirtschaftlichen Anreizen und Geldern und Krediten,
die, ich sage mal, ja, besser waren, aber doch aus Sicht der Ukraine erstmal
sehr attraktiv waren, weswegen man versucht hat, so einen Mittelweg zu fahren.
Und da hatte dann Ein Großteil der vor allem der Kiewer Bevölkerung oder der
städtischen Bevölkerung einfach
keine Lust zu oder wollte eben den Weg weiter in Richtung EU fahren.
Das war dann so ein bisschen die Quelle letztlich für die Gewalt,
für die Proteste, die dann auch gewalttätig wurden irgendwann.
Aber so sehe ich die Genesis des Ganzen quasi. Ein etwas naiver Westen könnte
man sagen oder taktloser Westen oder wie auch immer.
Wir sagten, ach Ukraine, komm doch dazu mit den anderen Ländern.
Hat das auch einigermaßen funktioniert und euch wird es auch besser gehen.
Und ja, und das ist halt eskaliert.
Das kann man sagen, dass es eskaliert ist. Also das kann natürlich alles jetzt
das Vorgehen Russlands nicht rechtfertigen.
Das sind alles Erklärungsversuche in irgendeiner Form nachzuvollziehen,
welche Ausreden sich die jeweiligen politischen Verantwortlichen gesucht haben,
was zu tun oder etwas nicht zu tun.
Am Ende muss man sagen, ist eigentlich die gesamte europäische Sicherheitspolitik
an der Stelle komplett gescheitert.
Also es ist halt einfach, man hat für dieses Land nicht die richtige Vision
gehabt und was sich halt auch immer wieder gezeigt hat auch gerade jetzt im
Verhalten Deutschlands seit Ausbruch des letzten Krieges, des Angriffs auf Kiew,
dass man einfach Schiss hat vor Russland.
Und dieses Zeigen von Schwäche eigentlich von Russland nur ausgenutzt wird.
Man hat halt einfach sich nicht entsprechend positioniert und niemals irgendeine
Drohkulisse aufgebaut, für aus dem Russland die Leere ziehen konnte,
okay alles klar, hier müssen wir einfach mal ein bisschen zurückrudern,
weil sonst könnte uns das irgendwie schaden.
Krim wurde annektiert, alle so, ja du du du du, mach das aber nicht nochmal.
So, das war ja im Wesentlichen so diese Reaktion. Da kam ja nix,
gab nur kleine Sanktionen.
Aber wir haben ja schon gesehen, selbst diese erheblichen Sanktionen,
die wir jetzt nach dem letzten Angriff gesehen haben, die über Russland herabgeregnet
sind, die das Land definitiv treffen. Nicht bis zur Unfähigkeit,
aber definitiv treffen.
Nichts, auch nur ansatzweise in dieser Größenordnung, ist damals auch nur überlegt
worden und ich glaube, das hätte schon was bewirken können.
Wobei die Sanktionen, stellt sich jetzt immer wieder heraus,
doch sehr löchrig sind, gegen Russland auch.
Oder was heißt löchrig?
Es gibt dann so Dinge, die in einem Krieg von sehr großem Nutzen sind,
die einfach bisher nicht unter Embargo standen,
wie zum Beispiel, ich meine, die eine Sache sind Öltanker, Der Verkauf von Öltankern
an Russland soll sanktioniert werden. Im Moment ist er nicht.
Russland kann sich einfach Öltanker kaufen, um sein Öl zu verschiffen.
LKW stehen auch nicht unter Sanktionen, das heißt für die Logistik hat sich
Russland oder bedient sich bisher
auch munter wohl auf den Weltmärkten und kauft halt schwere LKW ein,
um das zu ersetzen und und und.
Also viele Dinge, wo man denken würde, das ist aber nicht so gut,
dass Russland die einfach kaufen kann.
Aber ja, da denkt man unter Umständen dann nicht dran einfach jetzt LKWs zu sanktionieren.
Ja gut, aber es ist ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt der Westen die einzige Quelle
für Russland wäre, sondern oft steht das ja bei diesen Sanktionen auch so an,
also wenn wir das jetzt verbieten, dass wir das verkaufen, kann man schon machen.
Ja im Sinne von wir tun hier das Richtige, weil es ist ja moralisch nicht hilfreich.
So dann kommen halt die aus anderen Ländern. China springt gerne ein.
Sie profitieren indirekt sowieso erheblich von diesem Krieg,
indem sie halt ihre Energie günstiger bekommen und sicherlich eine ganze Menge
Dinge verkaufen. Also heutzutage sind alle Telefone und alle Autos,
die in Russland verkauft werden, sind halt jetzt chinesische Fabrikate.
Und davon haben sie genug im Angebot. Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Von daher, selbst wenn du solche Sanktionen beschließt, bringen sie dann auch
nicht unbedingt etwas, weil der Westen ist jetzt nicht… Die Zeiten,
wo wir der einzige Technologieversorger dieses Planeten waren, die sind halt vorbei.
Und von daher, lass es mich so sagen, also es ist natürlich richtig,
dass diese Sanktionen teilweise zu wünschen übrig lassen.
Ich glaube aber, dass wir mittlerweile an einem Punkt angekommen sind.
Wo der politische Wille Russland wirklich zu schaden und sie wirklich zu schwächen,
damit sie diesen Krieg nicht so durchführen können, wie sie ihn gerade durchführen, der ist da.
Der ist vielleicht nicht bei dem allerletzten Politiker da und Ungarn und solche
Probleme gibt es natürlich auch.
Und viele haben vielleicht auch noch zu viel Schiss hier und da die Stellschrauben
so hoch zu drehen, wie sie das vielleicht auch für richtig hielten eigentlich,
um nicht wiederum der lokalen Wirtschaft unnötig zu schaden.
Das ist alles klar, aber ich glaube, dass grundsätzlich der Wunsch da ist,
mit diesem Sanktionsschwert auch entsprechenden Schaden zuzuführen.
Aber als die Krim eingenommen wurde, war das halt nicht so.
Da war das halt eher ein politisches Signal.
So geht es aber nun wirklich nicht. Wir haben aber jetzt auch keinen Bock,
mit euch richtig Stress zu haben, weil wir kriegen ja auch irgendwie Gas und Öl von euch.
Also war es mehr ein politisches Symbol, als dass man wirklich jetzt bereit
war ins Risiko zu gehen, um Russland für diese Verletzung des Völkerrechts da
mal gerade stehen zu lassen.
Ähnlich auch die Situation in Georgien vorher, also auch dort hat Russland halt
nie wirklich Widerstand gespürt.
Der ist jetzt da, Russland macht natürlich trotzdem weiter, weil Putin sich
jetzt sozusagen einen Rückzug politisch überhaupt nicht leisten kann.
Jetzt geht es eigentlich nur noch um ihn.
Und das ist so ein bisschen das Problem. Und deswegen muss jetzt eben ein Widerstand
aufgebaut werden, der halt Russland auch wirklich aufzeigt, dass sie diesen
Krieg auch verlieren können und zwar richtig verlieren können.
Und da habert es noch. Da kommen wir dann aber auch noch zu.
Vielleicht zurück zum Euromaidan.
Das ist halt jetzt auch für die Ukraine ein wichtiges Datum,
weil es in gewisser Hinsicht das Datum ist, wo sich dieses Landkollektiv entschlossen
hat, diesen westlichen Weg zu gehen und einen Aufbruch in Richtung Demokratie zu wagen.
Das hat dann jahrelang nicht gut funktioniert und jetzt erst durch diese katalytische
Wirkung des letzten Krieges, denke ich mal, ist die Bereitschaft quasi unendlich groß.
Die Ukraine wird alles dafür tun, um in der EU aufgenommen zu werden.
Die Ukraine wird alles dafür tun, um in irgendeiner Form mit der NATO noch enger
zusammenzukommen bis hin zu einer richtigen Mitgliedschaft.
Das steht vollkommen außer Frage und ich denke auch nach wie vor.
Dass es sowohl für die EU, aber auch für die NATO ein Riesengewinn wäre letzten
Endes, hier die Ukraine auch als vollwertiges Mitglied aufzunehmen.
Klar, das mit der NATO hat viele Implikationen, aber auch das für die EU gar
keine Frage, weil das ist natürlich ein Land, das wenn wir das aufnehmen,
auch noch über Jahrzehnte einen Großteil der Förderung, die diese EU ausbreiten
kann, erhalten wird. würde, zu Recht auch.
Aber es ist halt auch ein großes wichtiges Agrarland, es ist ein großes wichtiges
Technologieland auch und davon kann Europa nur profitieren, abgesehen davon,
dass ich es für absolut richtig halte und für den richtigen moralischen Schritt
halte, wenn sich die EU wirklich als das Demokratiezentrum der Welt versteht.
Für das es sich eben hält, dann eben auch hier den Rücken durchzudrücken und
dann eben auch das entsprechende zu tun.
Weil alles andere ist meiner Auffassung nach alternativlos.
Die EU muss ganz klar sich zu ihren eigenen demokratischen Prinzipien bekennen
und dazu gehört es einfach die Ukraine in Schutz zu nehmen Und ganz klar hier
wieder eine neue Mauer aufzubauen,
wahrscheinlich auch gegenüber Russland,
solange bis dieses Land irgendwie mal wieder zu Sinnen kommt,
auch wenn es sich derzeit noch nicht so richtig abzeichnet, wann das sein sollte.
Kommen wir vielleicht dann auch mal zu dem Thema internationale Unterstützung für die Ukraine.
Wie sieht es denn da eigentlich gerade aus? Und als erstes, denke ich mal, ist es wichtig,
einen Blick auf die USA zu werfen, denn die USA,
naja, hat wie immer auch mit ihren eigenen Problemen zu kämpfen und das hat
dann eben auch Auswirkungen auf die aktuelle Unterstützung für die Ukraine,
die ja relativ groß und stark ist.
Die USA haben am meisten Geld und am meisten Waffen gestellt und sind generell
natürlich auch wichtig mit ihrer strategischen Unterstützung der Ukraine.
Aber die USA hat mit innenpolitischen Kämpfen ganz gut zu tun und das hat vor allem damit zu tun,
dass bei den letzten Midterm Elections, also diesen Zwischenwahlen,
die es ja immer gibt alle vier Jahre,
also kommen die normalen Präsidentschaftswahlen und da wird dann eben die Hälfte
des Kongresses auch neu gewählt und die andere Hälfte wird dann eben zwei Jahre später gewählt.
Das ist ja anders als bei uns, dass das Parlament immer komplett besetzt wird.
Sonst wird quasi alle zwei Jahre ist es möglich, hier eine Kräfteverschiebung zu haben.
Und leider sah eben die letzte Kräfteverschiebung so aus, dass die Republikaner
im Kongress wieder eine Mehrheit bekommen haben.
Zwar eine dünne Mehrheit, aber eine Mehrheit.
Und dann gab es ja erstmal diesen Sprecher Kevin McCarthy, der viele viele viele
Anläufe gebraucht hat bis er überhaupt mal gewählt wurde nur unter großen Zugeständnissen
gegenüber dieser lauten.
Ja ich weiß gar nicht, wie soll man diese Fraktion nennen, diesen Freedom Caucus,
das sind diese komplett rechtslastigen, russlandfreundlichen,
durchgedrehten Schwurbler, Verschwörungstheoretiker und sonstigen Rampfreunde,
die halt quasi diesen Speaker dort unter Zwang gestellt haben,
Ende so Deals zuzulassen, wie er kann dann auch, wenn auch nur einer das beantragt,
sehr abgewählt werden, wenn die Abstimmung entsprechend so läuft.
Und so kam es dann auch, dass eben Kevin McCarthy wieder abgewählt wurde und
dann dauerte es nochmal, ich weiß gar nicht, sechs Wochen oder so,
bis sie einen neuen Speaker gefunden haben, auf den sich alle einigen konnten.
Ein völlig unbekannter Hinterbänkler namens Mike Johnson ist es dann geworden,
aber auch so ein Bibeltreuer, rechtslastiger, schwulen Hasser,
der irgendwie ja jetzt hier diese Rolle ausfüllen soll und seitdem kräftig rumeiert.
Das ist insofern ein Problem, als dass wenn jetzt der Präsident möchte,
dass neue Ressourcen der Ukraine im Krieg bereitgestellt werden,
also Gelder freigegeben werden, dann muss das eben der Kongress beschließen.
Und der Kongress kann das aber nur dann beschließen, wenn es dem Kongress auch vorgelegt wird.
Und was dem Kongress zur Abstimmung vorgelegt wird, das entscheidet der Speaker.
Und der Speaker ist sozusagen der Mehrheitsführer und das ist eben genau dieser Mike Johnson.
Und was der jetzt bisher getan hat ist halt zu sagen so ja wir können da jetzt
gerne drüber abstimmen aber die Ukraine lassen wir mal raus.
Also es gibt im Prinzip derzeit drei heiße Eisen.
Das eine ist, es muss generell wieder das Funding für die Regierung sichergestellt werden.
Das ist immer so dieses politische Spiel, was sich da regelmäßig wiederholt,
wenn die Mehrheiten zwischen Präsident und Senat und Kongress unterschiedlich sind.
Das dann halt immer die Opposition, also ja, wir stellen euch jetzt keine Gelder
mehr bereit, ihr müsst irgendwie, ihr könnt jetzt niemanden mehr bezahlen,
ihr könnt das Militär nicht bezahlen, ihr könnt eure Leute nicht bezahlen,
wenn ihr nicht auch für unsere Forderungen eingeht.
Und dann wird immer irgendein Deal ausgehandelt und das war früher schon so,
aber es wird halt immer schärfer diese Auseinandersetzung und jetzt war es so,
naja, wir verlängern halt hier nicht das Funding der Regierung,
wenn ihr nicht für diese sinnlosen Sachen abstimmt und dazu gehört einerseits etwas,
was drin ist, sowas wie, wir wollen Kürzungen bei der Steuerbehörde,
damit reiche Leute nicht mehr so verfolgt werden können.
Solche Sachen sind da mit drin und dann eben vor allem so Geld für Israel,
klar, aber nicht für die Ukraine.
Und so geht das da die ganze Zeit hin und her.
Wobei es halt auch noch komplizierter ist, also nur um nochmal die Begriffe zu klären.
Also Congress ist halt Senat und Repräsentantenhaus zusammen.
Und das Repräsentantenhaus muss halt den Haushalt beschließen.
Dann muss der Senat dem zustimmen und dann muss der Präsident das unterzeichnen.
So ist der Weg.
Und die Demokraten stellen natürlich den Präsidenten und haben die Mehrheit im Senat.
In anderen Worten, egal was das Abgeordnetenhaus.
Das Und nicht beide Seiten dem Zustimmen bekommt es nicht durch.
Das ist ein bisschen anders als bei uns, wo einfach der Bundestag Dinge beschließen
kann, insofern das dann nicht von den Bundesländern zustimmungspflichtig ist,
das Ganze wird dann unmittelbar gesetzt.
Bei uns muss dann auch der Präsident das irgendwann unterzeichnen,
aber das ist mehr leider weniger eine Formalität, der hat jetzt nicht so in
dem Sinne ein etabliertes Veto-Recht, sondern mehr ein theoretisches Veto-Recht bei uns.
Und der Mike Johnson ist aber außerdem ein großer Israel-Freund und hat sich
da jetzt weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt, Israel zu unterstützen.
Die Demokraten haben einmal ganz klar gemacht,
dass sie Israel auch unterstützen wollen, aber wenn sie ein Gesetz machen,
dann muss das sowohl die Unterstützung für Israel als auch für die Ukraine enthalten.
Das ist jetzt die Situation.
An sich können die Demokraten ganz, ganz gut leben. Ich habe auch schon gesagt,
was jetzt passiert ist, ist, dass zweimal der Haushalt verlängert worden ist,
was im Wesentlichen der Haushalt ist, der mal von den Demokraten aufgestellt
wurde, sodass sie jetzt kein Problem damit haben.
Nur hatte man eben diese Rüstungsausgaben dort nicht mit einbezogen.
Und die zweite Verlängerung geht jetzt bis Januar,
also für einen Teil der Ausgaben bis Anfang Januar, für andere Ausgaben bis
Mitte Januar und einige Leute gehen davon aus,
dass wahrscheinlich die Abstimmung zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr passieren
wird über das Geld für Israel und die Ukraine,
weil da nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit auf Politik liegt in der Zeit und man das
so ein bisschen dann durchschmuggeln kann,
weil dieser Kompromiss dann wahrscheinlich beiden Seiten oder speziell den Republikanern
dann nicht so schmecken wird, der sich da jetzt gerade abzeichnet.
Die andere Sache ist, dass Mike Johnson jetzt als Hinterbänkler plötzlich Nummer 3 in der.
Rangfolge des Präsidenten, also es ist halt Präsident, Vizepräsident und dann
Mehrheitsführer im Repräsentantenhaus.
Falls jetzt Präsident und Vizepräsident ausfallen soll, ja, würde er zum Präsident werden.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Amt, also deutlich wichtiger
als jetzt ein deutscher Oppositionsführer. beziehungsweise in dem Moment gar
kein Oppositionsführer, sondern an der Stelle Mehrheitsführer.
Aber in Deutschland, weil bei uns das Parlament dann auch die Regierung wählt,
haben wir sehr selten den Zustand, dass die Regierung keine Mehrheit im Parlament hat.
Das ist in den USA natürlich, oder ist es anders?
Da kann theoretisch der Präsident von einer Seite, Senat von der anderen und
Repräsentantenhaus von der dritten, wenn es denn eine dritte gäbe.
Aber ja, also insofern im Moment Verzögerungen,
was zwar wohl nicht zu akuten Problemen gerade führt und die Regierung tut auch
alles dafür, die amerikanische um die Situation.
Ja um weiter liefern zu können einfach,
aber können schon davon ausgehen,
dass jetzt diese letzten zwei Monate doch zu einem Loch möglicherweise führen werden,
weil im Moment eben wahrscheinlich nicht so viel neue Dinge jetzt verabschiedet
oder auf den Weg gebracht werden wegen dieser Geschichte.
Aber sehr wahrscheinlich wird es so aussehen, dass irgendwann in den nächsten
Wochen das wohl verabschiedet werden wird. Das zeichnet sich zumindest ab bisher.
Ja gute Zusammenfassung also es ist wirklich ein komplexes Spiel und es ist
halt vor allem ein Spiel.
Also es geht hier um Verzögerung und hier
wird im wesentlichen die innenpolitische Karte gespielt weil natürlich läuft
alles auf die Wahlen im nächsten Jahr schon hinaus und es gibt halt einfach
immer noch sehr viel Trump Supporter und das Programm der Republikaner seit
einigen Jahren lautet ja eigentlich nur noch Disruption, Disruption, Disruption.
Immer dieser Kampf gegen den
allmächtigen Staat, so das ist so diese ganze libertäre Gesamtidentität,
die das alles immer ausspielt und dabei sind dann weltpolitische Zusammenhänge
für die Republikaner mittlerweile auch zweitrangig, den Eindruck hat es.
Was die Unterstützung für Israel betrifft, da ist es schwierig,
weil der Israel geneigte, wie heißt dieser Korkus, also es gibt sozusagen so
eine Lobbygruppe, die halt extrem pro israelisch ist, sehr großen Einfluss hat,
auch auf die Republikaner.
Dem können sie sich im Prinzip, da kommt viel zu viel Geld her,
das gegen Israel werden sie sich nicht stemmen.
Aber es gibt natürlich diese latente und teilweise auch wirklich unerklärliche,
ich würde schon fast sagen pro russische Haltung, die bei manchen Abgeordneten vertreten ist.
Die vielleicht andere republikanische Abgeordnete so nicht direkt sehen,
aber sich dem irgendwie hingeben und sozusagen zu argumentieren mit,
oh ja was haben wir mit der Ukraine zu tun und das ganze schöne Geld und so
weiter und das kostet ja nur den Steuerzahler.
Das ist halt so diese politische Argumentation, wie der amerikanische Wähler dagegen vorgeht.
Dass es natürlich ganz anders aussieht und dass die Amerikaner im Prinzip ja auch,
die Unterstützung der Ukraine ist ja sozusagen auch ein Wirtschaftsprogramm
für die USA, weil das meiste Geld, was dort ausgegeben wird,
das landet ja in den USA, weil das landet dann in der amerikanischen Rüstungsindustrie.
Von daher ist das natürlich alles Unsinn.
Die Unterstützung für die Ukraine in den USA in der Bevölkerung fällt eindeutiger
aus als die Unterstützung für Israel,
was vermutlich auch damit zusammenhängt,
dass die moralische Situation in der Ukraine übersichtlicher und einfacher ist.
Die Russen sind da einmarschiert und die Ukraine hat das Recht,
dort ihr souveränes Territorium zu verteidigen. Beim Israel-Palästina-Konflikt,
ist,
es ein bisschen komplizierter.
Und das scheint sich auch auf
die Meinung generell in der amerikanischen Bevölkerung durchzuschlagen.
Ja die Frage, also das eine ist natürlich Pols, das andere ist,
was findet bei den Wahlen tatsächlich statt.
Irgendwie geben sich die Republikaner nach wie vor dieser Illusion hin,
dass Trump sozusagen der Weg ist, den man gehen muss.
Einfach weil er irgendwie diese schreienden Massen hinter sich hat.
Aber man muss auch sehen, Trump hat bisher alle Wahlen, seit seiner Präsidentenwahl,
die er knapp gewonnen hat, hat er alle Wahlen verloren und zwar krachend.
Auch diese Midtermselection, wo sie zwar wieder die Mehrheit im Repräsentantenhaus,
korrekte Formulierung, bekommen haben, war im Prinzip eine Niederlage.
Weil sie halt alle irgendwie eine rote Welle vorhergesagt haben und da kam halt nichts.
Dass sie also überhaupt noch eine Mehrheit am Ende hatten, das war dann schon
fast Glück, das war auf jeden Fall super knapp.
Auch alle Nachwahlen, die irgendwo stattfinden und insbesondere spezielle Abstimmungen
über das Abtreibungsgesetz in einzelnen Staaten, nicht das Gesetz,
sondern die Regelung zur Abtreibung. Die Ertragen hat ja mit seinen...
Appointees für den Supreme Court, also quasi das Verfassungsgericht der USA,
dafür gesorgt, dass es halt eine Mehrheit, also eine rechtslastige Mehrheit
gibt in diesem Supreme Court.
Und das führte ja dazu, dass so eine Rechtsprechung, eine generelle Rechtsprechung
gegenüber Abtreibung geändert wurde, die sogenannte Role versus Weight Entscheidung,
die sozusagen wieder das Verbot von Abtreibung ermöglicht.
Und viele Bundesstaaten haben das dann auch ganz schnell in Gesetze überführt
und da in einigen Bundesländern auch schon zu großen Problemen geführt.
Und andere Länder haben aber dann wiederum zu dieser Problematik bei Wahlen
entsprechende Abstimmungen für Gesetzesänderungen oder Verfassungsänderungen
in den Staaten aufgerufen,
die dann in der Regel alle angenommen wurden.
Das heißt, viele Bundesstaaten wehren sich jetzt sozusagen dahingehend,
dass einfach in die Staatsverfassung der einzelnen Bundesstaaten oder des jeweiligen
Bundesstaates reingeschrieben wird, dass ein Verbot nicht okay ist.
Und man sieht einfach, dass eigentlich die Republikaner in der amerikanischen
Bevölkerung nicht mehr wirklich einen Halt haben. Also es misst keinen ausreichenden.
Und dass eben auch das ganze Gerrymandering der letzten Jahrzehnte nicht mehr zu helfen scheint.
Nur am Ende ist immer die Frage bei der Wahl, wie viele dieser Leute,
die eine Meinung haben, wählen auch.
Und es gab halt bei der Wahl zu Präsident Biden, gab es eine große Bewegung,
Antitrump, das hat halt gereicht.
Ob das dann eben bei den nächsten Wahlen wieder so ist, wird sich zeigen.
Derzeit ist die Präsidentschaft von Biden laut Pols sehr unpopulär,
wo ich mich eigentlich frage, warum eigentlich, aber so ist das halt einfach
in dieser Wahrnehmung, weil ich finde das, was die Demokraten da derzeit machen,
ist im Großen und Ganzen wirklich okay.
Ja, das kann man im Detail natürlich alles kritisieren, da bin ich jetzt auch
weit von entfernt, das ist dann im Wesentlichen auch amerikanische Innensicht.
Was sie halt mit diesem Infrastructure gemacht haben, was sie da sozusagen an
Klimainvestitionen, Investitionen in Elektromobilität schon erreicht haben,
da träumen wir ja von in Europa.
Und auch die internationale Grundhaltung der beiden Administrationen zu Konflikten
eben wie in der Ukraine, China und so weiter around the world ist halt vertretbar.
Also sozusagen die USA tut wieder was und wir haben ja alle gesehen,
wie schlimm es war in der Trump-Zeit, dass es fast ja so aussah,
als ob die komplette Weltordnung zusammenbricht.
Dementsprechend ist das alles kritisch, wie die sich jetzt gerade verhalten.
Ja, aber ich finde das so, dass Biden in vielen Dingen eher rechter ist als
seine bisherigen demokratischen Vorgänger.
Insofern ist er weiter in der Mitte und weniger links, aber das scheint ihm
auch nicht unbedingt zu helfen.
Ja, und dann ist es so, dass eher innenpolitische Themenwahlen entscheidend sind.
Außenpolitik ist, glaube ich, generell in den USA nicht so das,
was im Vordergrund steht oder das,
was bei den Leuten so in den Köpfen ist oder kein vordringliches Problem.
Und was jetzt Roe vs.
Wade angeht, was ich richtig sehe, war das eigentliche Problem,
dass der Gesetzgeber keine vernünftigen Gesetze gemacht hat und damals deswegen
das Verfassungsgericht in den USA, also der Supreme Court quasi,
als Ersatzgesetzgeber fungiert hat und man das nun wiederum umgeworfen hat,
sodass jetzt die Politik aufgerufen ist.
Entsprechende Gesetze zu machen, die das Ganze regelt.
Und wie du richtig gesagt hast, sieht es so aus, dass das, was die Republikaner
sich da vorstellen an Abtreibungsrecht nicht besonders populär ist und dass
sie jetzt in Panik geraten,
weil sie jetzt Roe vs.
Wade gekippt haben, dass jetzt in der Gegenbewegung Gesetze kommen,
die so ein eher liberales Abtreibungsrecht dann wohl zur Folge haben werden.
Das ist das, was zumindest jetzt passiert, sagt es in einem Bundesland nach
dem anderen, und dass es ja auch diese Pro-Leifer einfach nicht mehrheitsfähig sind.
Für die Ukraine heißt es jetzt erstmal warten. Es wird jetzt allgemein davon
ausgegangen, dass der ganze Hickhack sich gegen Ende des Jahres dahingehend lösen wird.
Dass einfach die beiden Administrationen sagen, bitte einfach alles vergessen.
Wir werden nichts zustimmen, wo nicht Israel und Ukraine eine Zusage bekommen.
Und da sich eben die Republikaner nicht leisten können, Unterstützung für Israel
zu versagen, wird es eben dazu kommen. Das ist so derzeit die Einschätzung.
Inwiefern dann in so einem Kompromiss die Zahlen noch nach unten gedrückt werden
für die Ukraine, oder was an anderen Pitfalls noch mit eingebaut wird, wissen wir nicht.
Wird sich zeigen. Aber ich glaube, erstens, es gibt im Repräsentantenhaus,
wie auch im Senat, auch bei den Republikanern eine Mehrheit für die Unterstützung der Ukraine.
Also das ist sozusagen jetzt eigentlich alles nur so ein bisschen die Revolution
von rechts innerhalb der republikanischen Partei, die einfach verstört ist durch
diesen ganzen Trumpismus, der sie wie Krebs befallen hat.
Und die langfristige Strategie der USA wird vor allem von den nächsten Wahlen
abhängen und da ist es natürlich ein bisschen schwierig, dass jetzt die ganze
Unterstützung für die Ukraine, eben weil, wie du schon richtig gesagt hast,
sich generell die Amerikaner eigentlich für internationale Politik nicht interessieren.
Ja, wissen wir ja, jeder Blick auf die Welt ist schwierig und so weiter.
Das ist sozusagen nicht das, was drängend ist. Das sind einfach die innenpolitischen
Themen. Das ist ja bei uns auch nicht anders.
Du kannst ja keine Bundestagswahl gewinnen mit deinem Verhältnis zum Afghanistan-Konflikt oder so.
Das wird zwar mal diskutiert oder so, aber auch mit Ukraine und so weiter kriegst
du hier keinen Blumentopf, sondern am Ende zählen halt, was weiß ich,
Diskussionen um Parkplätze oder Straßenbahnen oder sowas. Das regt die Leute dann immer auf.
Daran werden wir wahrscheinlich auch wenig ändern können. Also muss man gucken, wie das ausgeht.
Ich bin da noch verhalten optimistisch, dass die Demokraten sich auch ein weiteres
Mal durchsetzen können, auch wenn es natürlich schwierig ist,
zu argumentieren, dass Trump zu alt ist, wenn Biden noch älter ist und so weiter.
Da sind alles solche Details, da muss man eben mal gucken, wie sich das so entwickelt.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, glaube ich, bleibt die USA auf Linie.
Also Trump wird es wohl kaum werden und wenn es Trump,
ja, nee, das ist allein wegen den ganzen Gerichtsverfahren, die anhängig sind,
das alleine wird glaube ich zu seiner Disqualifikation führen.
Und das hält er nicht durch.
Ja, haben wir auch schon mal geglaubt.
Die Mühlen malen langsam aber ständig und so nach und nach, jetzt merkt man,
ich verfolge das auch regelmäßig,
was da in den ganzen Prozessen gegen Trump abgeht.
Und ja, das sieht ganz ganz schlecht aus.
Das stimmt, das sieht schlecht aus, aber ich glaube das halt auch erst wenn es soweit ist.
Und vor allem in dem Moment wo er aus dem Präsidentschaftsrennen genommen wird
durch einen juristischen Beschluss,
sagen wir mal er wird irgendwo verurteilt
und darf deswegen gar nicht mehr antreten oder sitzt im Knast so.
Dann hast du natürlich das nächste Problem, dieser ganze Märtyrerkult,
der dann zu innenpolitischen Verwerfungen führen wird.
Also der USA stehen noch heiße Zeiten bevor, was das betrifft.
Das Trump-Problem ist noch nicht gelöst und inwiefern sich das eben auf diesen
Ukraine-Konflikt auswirkt, das werden wir noch sehen.
Es wirkt sich jetzt insofern schon aus, als dass eben die USA in so einer Warte-Abwarte-Haltung,
ist,
und in so einem innenpolitischen Poker gefangen ist und nicht klar international,
mit dem Rückhalt der gesamten amerikanischen Gesellschaft auftreten kann und
sagen kann hier Russland macht mal halblang, sonst gibt es Ärger.
Und das wäre das, was eigentlich erforderlich ist. Da kommen wir auch gleich
nochmal zu. Jetzt sollten wir vielleicht nochmal einen Blick werfen auf die
Hilfen der EU und fangen wir doch einfach mal mit Deutschland an,
da gibt es ausnahmsweise ja mal gute Nachrichten.
Ja, ich meine in 2024 soll die Ukraine mit 8 statt bisher 4 Milliarden unterstützt werden.
Das wurde so vor zehn Tagen von der Regierung so vermeldet.
Beschlossen ist es noch nicht. Wir haben ja jetzt auch in Deutschland neue Haushaltsturbulenzen.
Deswegen wird man sehen, aber zumindest vorher war die Absicht war und ist,
acht statt bisher vier Milliarden an die Ukraine zu geben.
Sowohl an wirtschaftlicher Hilfe als auch an militärischer Hilfe zusammen.
Und mittlerweile, ja,
während es am Anfang alles sehr zögerlich anlief,
wenn man sich jetzt die Liste anguckt, die da ständig aktualisiert wird beim
Verteidigungsministerium, dann ist die imposant.
Sehr viel Kleinkram, also von sich Nachtsichtgeräten über spezielle Radarsysteme,
Bodenradarsysteme und jede Menge medizinischer, was weiß ich,
für Zahnarztbehandlung an der Front und hast du nicht gesehen?
Alles Sachen, die wichtig sind, die aber keine großen Headlines machen.
Und so an größeren Items tatsächlich, was mich überrascht hat,
bisher sind drei IRIS-T SLM-Systeme geliefert,
worden.
Das erste hatte ja relativ lange auf sich warten lassen, aber mittlerweile sind
es drei und eins soll wohl noch im Dezember kommen. Also hemmen sie vier.
Und im nächsten Jahr, wurde jetzt gerade angekündigt, sollen noch mal vier weitere dazu kommen.
Außerdem stehen auf der Liste auch eine ganze Menge IRIS-T-SLS-Systeme.
Das ist Variante auch für Flugabwehr. Allerdings mit einer noch etwas kürzeren
Reichweite, aber auch billigeren Raketen.
So die, glaube ich, aus Skandinavien, ich glaube in Schweden oder so hergestellt werden.
Aber plus eben die können dann halt normale IRIS-T SLS vom Boden verschießen,
die man normalerweise nur an Flugzeuge, oder die ursprünglich dazu waren,
um die an Flugzeuge ranzuschrauben.
Und des Weiteren haufenweise auch Leopard 1 Kampfpanzer, die jetzt kommen und
Gepard-Systeme auch in größeren Stückzahlen.
Bisher sind schon über 30 Systeme geliefert worden und es kommen noch mal in
der Größenordnung demnächst dazu.
Also dürfte wahrscheinlich in kürze die ukraine der der größte operator,
ja für gepaarte am meisten nutzen davon haben gerade ja ja ja und natürlich
leopard 2 auch mittlerweile,
in eher moderaten Stückzahlen, aber die kommen auch, plus diverse Panzerkampfwagen
und LKWs in größerer Zahl.
Also Hunderte von Sattelschleppern hat Deutschland geliefert,
so Arctros, diese Mercedes-Sattelschlepper.
Sehr wichtig für die Logistik.
Ja, also mittlerweile muss man sagen, muss man sich jetzt als Deutscher nicht
mehr schämen für die Ukraine Unterstützung, die geleistet wird.
Nee, schämen vielleicht nicht, aber ich finde natürlich, Es ist nie genug.
Erstens ist es nie genug und zweitens, also auch acht Milliarden klingt irgendwie
viel, aber das wird alles nicht ausreichen, kommen wir ja auch noch zu.
Aber die so kritische Sachen wie zum Beispiel, die das nicht liefern dieser
Taurus Raketen, man kann jetzt darüber diskutieren, ob die jetzt ein Game Changer sind oder nicht.
Die ganze Debatte mit verschiedenen Waffen, ist das jetzt ein Game Changer und so.
Alles hilft. Und wenn die Ukraine sagt, das und das kann uns helfen,
dann sollen wir es einfach liefern. Aber dieses politische Hickhack und dann
wieder so, ja, ach nee, und damit könnte man ja auch Russland treffen und so
weiter, so, ja, ich weiß.
Darum geht es übrigens auch gerade, Russland zu treffen.
Ob man jetzt Russland auf ukrainischem Boden oder Russland auf russischem Boden
trifft, finde ich, spielt derzeit einfach, macht überhaupt keinen Unterschied mehr.
Völkerrechtlich ist das völlig in Ordnung. Wenn Russland Ukraine angreift,
dann kann selbstverständlich Russland auch auf russischem Boden getroffen werden.
Das ist vollkommen durch das Völkerrecht gedeckt.
Wenn das also gedeckt ist, wo ist das Problem?
Warum hat man dann ein Problem damit, wenn irgendwie eine deutsche Missile auf
Infrastruktur in Russland runter geht?
Klar man will natürlich kein Massaker unter Zivilisten machen,
aber das hat die Ukraine ja auch gezeigt, dass sie sich mit sowas gar nicht
groß aufhalten, weil sie wissen,
für sie zählt nur militärischer Erfolg und der geht nicht durch Terror von Zivilisten
einher, sondern der funktioniert durch das gezielte Ausschalten von Infrastruktur,
wie zum Beispiel wie wir schon gesehen haben, diese Hubschrauberlandeplätze.
Also jetzt gibt es einen Hubschrauberlandeplatz in Russland,
in dem Moment wo man halt Long Range Missiles hätte, die man auch auf russischem Gebiet einsetzen darf,
also auf Basis der Vereinbarung, die man eben mit den Geberländern getroffen
hat, so weiter, sind die dann auch weg.
Und das ist halt einfach, es könnte so viel erreicht werden.
Durch das bedingungslose bereitstellen dieser waffensysteme die sowieso hier
rumliegen und keiner braucht also wozu haben wir die denn eigentlich wenn ich
genau jetzt für diesen fall ja das dafür habe ich einfach kein verständnis also
überhaupt kein verständnis.
Ich würde nachher noch ein bisschen was zu der denke sagen warum das warum das so ist.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall das Paket ist da. Schauen wir vielleicht jetzt auch
nochmal darauf wie es im Rest der EU aussieht.
Also wir haben ja da auch ein gespaltenes Bild.
Es gibt Länder die halt die Ukraine auch extrem stark unterstützen.
Vor allem natürlich die ganzen osteuropäischen Länder, also zu Polen muss man
glaube ich gar nicht viel sagen und die baltischen Republiken auch geben alles, was sie können.
Ich habe jetzt gerade eine Nachricht gelesen, war es Estland oder war es Lettland,
eines von den beiden glaube ich, wo das Land jetzt der Ukrainer auch Pkw bereitstellt,
die sie von betrunkenen Autofahrern konfisziert haben.
Also straight, da hat irgendjemand sein Recht auf sein eigenes Fahrzeug verwirkt,
weil er irgendwie zu oft oder zu sehr besoffen durch die Gegend gefahren ist.
Kann man jetzt darüber diskutieren, ob das sozusagen eine angemessene Maßnahme
ist, die Autos generell einzuziehen, aber wenn sie schon da sind,
sie dann einfach gleich in die Ukraine
weiterzuleiten, finde ich das schon irgendwie ein geiles Statement.
Finnland und Schweden denke ich mal sind auch ganz klar auf der Unterstützerseite,
Dänemark ist insbesondere mit Holland zusammen auf der F16 Front ganz vorne,
also die bemühen sich nach Kräften so schnell wie möglich diese Kampfflugzeuge
in die Ukraine zu bringen und soweit ich weiß sind jetzt auch schon die ersten
zumindest nach Rumänien geliefert worden, wo halt jetzt die Kampfpiloten ausgebildet werden.
Und klar, Deutschland gibt am meisten, was sozusagen Geld betrifft,
aber ich meine das ist ja auch eh klar, weil wir sind ja nun mal das reichste
Land und daher haben wir auch am meisten zu geben.
So, und dann gibt es natürlich die Ausfälle. Also allen voran natürlich Ungarn.
Keine Ahnung, über Orban muss man glaube ich nicht viel Worte verlieren,
aber ich finde es schon einfach beyond frech, wie russlandfreundlich die auftreten und ukrainefeindlich.
Also das wird auf jeden Fall Konsequenzen haben für dieses Land, hoffe ich zumindest.
Und jetzt kommt leider auch noch Slowenien mit dazu, die jetzt gerade Wahlen hatten.
Slowakei oder?
Entschuldigung, Slowakei. Ich muss mal in beiden Ländern mal gewesen sein,
dann ist das Ding durch, weil ich war weder in der Slowakei noch in Slowenien,
Asche auf meinen Haupt, sorry.
Slowenien ist sehr, sehr nett. Slowenien ist wirklich toll.
Ja, ich weiß es. Wahrscheinlich ist auch die Slowakei ganz toll,
aber ihre Politik nervt gerade.
Jetzt haben sie sich halt eine neue Regierung besorgt, die ein bisschen zwiegespalten ist.
Also die jetzt erstmal sagt, wir unterstützen jetzt erstmal die Ukraine nicht mehr.
Das tut sie allerdings trotzdem noch insofern, als dass slowakische Rüstungsunternehmen
nach wie vor ihre Aufträge, die sie haben, da bedienen und ich glaube auch Reparaturen
vornehmen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau.
Also es scheint so ein bisschen gespaltene Zunge zu sein.
Definitiv ist aber die Slowakei jetzt eher ein weiterer Problembär und man muss
gucken, wie sich das entwickelt.
Insbesondere nach den Wahlen in Polen, da steht ja jetzt eine neue Regierung
an. Die alte PiS-Partei ist jetzt abgewählt worden.
Hurra. Jetzt dauert es aber noch ein bisschen, weil der Präsident die Regierungsbildung
noch weiter verzögert und so weiter kann und damit wahrscheinlich hier alle
ihre Schäfchen ins Trockene bringen können vorher.
Auf jeden Fall sieht es aber ganz danach aus, dass wir dann eine sehr provestliche
polnische Regierung erhalten werden und dann kann ich mir auch vorstellen,
dass auf der Achse dann wiederum mehr läuft.
So und dann hoffentlich auch gegen Ungarn mal vorgegangen werden kann,
wenn sich jetzt nicht die Slowakei wieder quer stellt.
Das Interessante in Polen ist,
dass es in Polen egal ist, ob man jetzt das,
was gemeinhin als liberale Denke bezeichnet wird oder bei uns vielleicht eher
sagen mehr linksdemokratische Denke gebietet es,
die Ukraine zu unterstützen,
aber in Polen gebietet es auch das realpolitische Denken.
Also wenn man jetzt komplett auf irgendwelches Recht scheißt und in erster Linie
das Ganze nur machtpolitisch sieht,
auch dann hat Polen ganz klares Interesse daran.
Russland entgegen zu treten.
Also mit anderen Worten, Linke wie auch Rechte in Polen haben beide aus unterschiedlichsten
Gründen ein Interesse daran, die Ukraine zu unterstützen.
Von der ukrainisch großen ukrainischen Minderheit in Polen mal ganz zu schweigen
Ja die EU selber ist nach wie vor auch ein Unterstützer der Ukraine so weit
Ungarn sie es denn lässt Das ist natürlich das Problem,
dass Ungarn sich jetzt die ganze Zeit dagegen sperrt, dass die EU Gelder freigibt etc.
Was noch mehr im Mittelpunkt steht ist natürlich die ganze Diskussion um einen
möglichen Beitritt der Ukraine zur EU Da geht's voran, habe ich ja vorhin schon
angedeutet, insofern als das eben weiterhin bekräftet wird,
dass eben die Ukraine da generell auf einem guten Weg sei.
Ukraine selber möchte gerne, dass das alles noch viel schneller geht.
Ich frage mich, welches realistisch zeitliche Ziel es hier geben kann,
bis so ein Beitritt tatsächlich umgesetzt werden kann Inwiefern der Krieg als
solches einen Beitritt auf unbegrenzte Zeit hinaus verzögern könnte? Wie siehst du das?
Also ich glaube, solange der Krieg läuft und es keine halbwegs belastbare Regelung gibt,
die ein Wiederaufschlammen verhindert, wird es weder einen Beitritt zur EU noch
zur NATO geben und das kann halt sehr, sehr lange dauern.
Also ich rechne da eher mit jenseits von zehn Jahren.
Wir reden jetzt mit zehn Jahren, dass dieser Konflikt weitergeht?
Ja, bevor die vergehen, bevor tatsächlich irgendwelche Beitritte erfolgen.
Und dann hängt es ja noch davon ab, wie der Konflikt ausgeht.
Ob der Westen irgendwann sagt, nee, das ist uns zu teuer und wir lassen das jetzt.
Oder die westlichen Bevölkerungen dann keinen Bock mehr drauf haben.
Also dass wir quasi kapitulieren.
Ich meine, ist jetzt auch nicht so ausgeschlossen, also zumindest was die USA
angeht, oder auch Deutschland hat ja in Afghanistan kapituliert irgendwann.
Und anderen Dingen, also es ist jetzt auch nicht ausgeschlossen,
dass jetzt, ich sag mal, wir in Anführungszeichen verlieren,
wie auch immer das aussieht.
Ich meine, Russland wird nicht die gesamte Ukraine besetzen,
das wird auch nicht funktionieren.
Ich denke es wird da auch irgendeinen Kompromiss geben müssen.
Egal wie dieser Konflikt zu dem Zeitpunkt aussieht. Also eine sehr enge Assoziation ist wichtig.
Vor allem denke ich mal dieses Bekräftigen der Perspektive ist extrem wichtig,
weil das eben dazu führt, dass die Ukraine auch alle Anstrengungen unternimmt,
den Standard, den sie einfach haben müssen.
Also was erstmal ihre Rechtsstruktur betrifft, Demokratie abgesichert ist,
Freiheit der Presse etc.
Also all diese ganzen Faktoren, die für Ungarn ja offensichtlich keine Rolle
zu spielen scheinen, dass das sozusagen hinkommt und dass diese Reformen innerhalb
des Landes trotz des Krieges auch weiterhin gewollt werden.
Das ist glaube ich erstmal das wichtigste, weil so oder so wird es natürlich
viele Jahre dauern, Bis all diese Regelungen so umgesetzt sind,
dass das Land quasi formal EU-kompatibel ist.
Ob man dann den letzten Schritt, der und jetzt machen wir auch wirklich mal
das hier mit der Aufnahme, wann der dann konkret erfolgt, das steht ja nochmal auf dem anderen Blatt.
Aber es spricht ja einiges dafür, die Ukraine so weit zu motivieren,
überhaupt erstmal ihr System EU-kompatibel zu machen.
Um dann zu schauen, wie die Situation ist. Da gibt es ja in dem Sinne jetzt
auch gar keine Zeit zu verlieren.
Abgesehen davon natürlich, dass die Ukraine durch den Krieg Härten hat,
die jetzt ein normaler Beitrittskandidat so in der Regel ja nicht hat.
Aber das werden wir gleich auch nochmal diskutieren in der Gesamteinschätzung,
wie man jetzt eigentlich weitergehen kann. Wollen wir den EU-Teil erstmal abschließen?
Ja, vielleicht eins noch zum Thema EU und diese gesamte Rechtsstruktur und Institutionen
und so, die man schaffen muss.
Es gibt gewisse Kritik dahingehend an diesem ganzen EU-Brimborium,
nenne ich das mal, dass das in erster Linie entwickelt wurde für reiche,
entwickelte Industrieländer.
Das heißt, dass das sozusagen der optimale Rechtsrahmen ist.
Und dass viele der Schwierigkeiten, die auch dann mit Beitritt Ostblock-Ländern.
Eingetreten sind, daran lagen,
dass es eben nicht der optimale wirtschaftliche Rahmen für Länder in dieser
Situation sind, wo massive Veränderungen notwendig sind, wo aber auch großes
Wachstumspotenzial vorhanden ist.
Die Kritik ist, dass die EU-Regularien.
Oder Richtlinien ein zu formales Korsett sind für Länder, die sich in einer
gänzlich anderen Situation befinden als jetzt Deutschland oder Frankreich oder
Italien oder wie auch immer.
Ich glaube, das ist auch nicht völlig von der Hand zu weisen,
aber vielleicht hat man das mittlerweile jetzt auch erkannt und daraus gelernt und guckt halt,
dass man das mit der Ukraine dann vielleicht ein bisschen,
großzügiger handhabt,
was auch immer das bedeuten mag.
Also ich wollte nur sagen.
Es ist vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlimm, wenn das mit dem EU-Beitritt nicht
sofort erfolgt, sondern man quasi mit Aussicht auf EU-Beitritt,
aber erst mal, dass das Land dann entwickelt und ja, und es erst mal gewisse Freiheiten noch hat.
Dinge anders zu tun, als nach EU-Vorschriften der Fall sein müsste.
Also Mülltrennung oder so.
Ja guter Punkt. Ja aber ich finde es gerade in dem Hinblick auch okay diesen
Prozess zu beschreiten, allein
damit die EU auch versteht, dass sie ihren Prozess da anpassen muss.
Also das sozusagen, man wird ja sicherlich dann aus dem Beitritt der anderen
osteuropäischen Länder schon einiges gelernt haben in dieser Hinsicht,
weil das waren ja in dem Sinne auch keine großen, teilweise sind es schon industrielle Länder.
Ich meine, Ukraine ist auch teilweise ein Industrieland, sie haben ja Industrie,
nur eben nicht vorherrschend und deswegen müssen glaube ich beide Seiten in
diesem Prozess eintreten.
Ja,
jetzt sollten wir auf jeden Fall auch nochmal die Situation in Russland selber
beleuchten, weil man sich ja sowieso immer die ganze Zeit wundert,
was ist eigentlich mit Russland los,
warum drehen die alle so am Rad und welche Möglichkeiten hat Russland derzeit
eigentlich noch diesen Konflikt weiter am Laufen zu halten,
beziehungsweise welche Chance hat die russische Bevölkerung und die Gesellschaft
an sich dort eine Möglichkeit,
dem Ganzen vielleicht auch nochmal Einhalt zu gebieten.
Erstmal kann man festhalten, dass wohl derzeit ca.
400.000 russische Soldaten in der Ukraine kämpfen, was deshalb bemerkenswert
ist, weil es doppelt so viele sind, wie bei der Invasion zu Beginn.
Da ist durchaus was passiert, das hatten wir auch gesagt,
das ist jetzt mit Geld versuchen und das einigermaßen funktioniert und zumindest
öffentlich zeigt sich Russland zufrieden mit den Rekrutenzahlen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite gibt es jetzt Zahlen, die bekannt geworden sind,
dass nur wenige Regionen ihre Quoten erreicht haben.
Also es gibt krasse Unterschiede. Liste gesehen, da war eine Handvoll,
die wirklich auf 100 Prozent gekommen sind, also so viele Rekruten geliefert haben, wie sie sollten,
während andere eher in der Größenordnung oft dann auch nur bei 10 oder 20 Prozent lagen.
Jetzt natürlich die Frage, was hat es da mit den Quoten auf sich?
Altes sowjetisches System, da wurde, gab es halt früher für alles irgendwie
Quoten und Und dann mit den Quoten ist halt so dieses übliche Spiel,
man will nicht 100 Prozent erreichen, weil dann im nächsten Jahr die Quote erhöht
wird oder beim nächsten Mal,
man will aber auch nicht ganz am Ende landen mit seiner Quote,
weil das dann sehr negative Auswirkungen auf die eigene Karriere oder Gesundheit haben kann.
Und so sieht es wohl dort gerade aus, aber ganz offensichtlich reicht es ja
nicht, um durchschlagende Erfolge zu erzielen.
Und ich sagte ja auch, im Grunde genommen müsste Russland statt 400.000 eher
mit 2-3 Millionen Soldaten,
die Ukraine angreifen, um tatsächlich durchschlagenen Erfolg zu haben.
Ob es jemals zu so einer Mobilisierung kommen wird, ist sehr fraglich,
weil dafür auch das Material fehlt.
Aber es wird auch erwartet, dass Putin nach der Wahl im März,
obwohl er jetzt seine Kandidatur noch nicht öffentlich bekannt gegeben hat,
aber dass dann danach, wenn er dann quasi wieder seine,
ja für, ich glaube lässt sich gleich für zwei Amtsperioden wählen oder so.
Dass dann erwartet wird, dass das Land dann voll für den Krieg mobilisiert.
Also dass sie dann richtig noch mal einen drauflegen.
Ob das passieren wird, wirklich schwer zu sagen, weil im Moment wird der Krieg
von vielen Russen einfach nur ignoriert und das Risiko,
wenn das Ganze jetzt plötzlich zum Thema wird und auch der Erfolg im Krieg zum
großen Thema wird in Russland, dass auch Widerstand gegen die Regierung mobilisieren könnte.
Insofern ist das möglich. Aber bisher hat Putin erstaunlich viel Zurückhaltung gezeigt,
also mehr als man erwartet hatte, was jetzt so die Mobilisierung und Umstellung
auf Kriegswirtschaft angeht.
Dass es ist sagen Putin scheint das Ganze noch immer halbherzig zu betreiben und so halbherzig,
dass eben der Krieg von den meisten Russen ignoriert wird und sie auch nichts
damit zu tun haben wollen.
So das ist ja das ist weit weg und ja da kümmern sich die Profis drum.
Das scheint bei vielen Russen die Sicht zu sein und ansonsten können sie sowieso nichts dagegen tun.
Das ist halt höhere Gewalt aus Sicht der Russen, Schicksal.
A.
So ist das halt.
Ja, ja.
Das könnte sich aber ändern, wenn also wirklich eine volle Mobilisierung stattfindet,
also in dem Moment, wo also wirklich diese Special Military Operation zum Krieg
ausgerufen wird, wo dann jeder weiß,
jetzt wird auch vielleicht in Moskau und in Sankt Petersburg rekrutiert und
dazu sind ja auch die Gesetze in letzter Zeit entsprechend schon angepasst worden,
das Einzugsalter ist hochgesetzt worden.
Die Dauer, die Vertragsbedingungen, es wird zwar viel Geld versprochen,
aber im Prinzip kommt man da nie wieder raus, wenn man einmal drin ist.
Leute werden auch rekrutiert, selbst wenn sie krank sind etc.
Das sind halt alles so Dinge, die dann irgendwie über die Zeit dann auch rücksickern
und ich denke bei einer vollen Mobilisierung,
dann wird es auch spannend sein zu sehen, inwiefern die Gesellschaft dann trotzdem
noch diesen Krieg ignorieren will,
weil dann wird es halt auch irgendwann mal in die großen Städte,
in die eigentlichen russischen Städte und nicht die Städte, die derzeit im Wesentlichen
betroffen sind und die Gebiete, die derzeit betroffen sind,
nämlich die fern von Moskau und fern von St.
Petersburg liegenden Regionen, die ja im Wesentlichen das Material,
das Menschenmaterial derzeit für diesen Krieg stellen.
Welche Auswirkungen das dann hat, das wird man dann sehen. Aber in dem Moment,
wo Russland voll mobilisiert, muss sich natürlich der Westen auch überlegen, was er dann macht.
Ja,
wirtschaftlich sieht es so aus, eigentlich war erwartet worden,
dass jetzt Ende des Jahres der Regierung das Geld ausgeht.
Ganz so schlimm scheint es jetzt nicht gekommen zu sein, weil unter anderem
die Öleinnahmen höher sind,
als man das erhofft hatte, weil mittlerweile Russland es geschafft hat,
einen Großteil des Öls zu höheren Preisen als die vom Westen festgelegte Obergrenze
von 60 Dollar pro Barrel exportiert.
Also die schaffen es wohl im Moment, einen Großteil des Öls für 70 oder mehr
zu verkaufen, also praktisch fast zu Marktpreisen.
Und ja, Russland verschifft halt das Öl dann mit Tankern, die eben keine westliche Versicherung haben.
Und deshalb dann jetzt wieder auch so weitere Gegenmaßnahmen überlegt wurden,
sodass Dänemark zum Beispiel da,
wie Meerenge in der Ostsee für russische Öltanker sperrt und eben der Verbot
von Verkauf von Tankern an Russland und so, weil eben dort, ja,
Russland das mit dem Ölexporten halbwegs umgeht.
Allerdings häufen sich jetzt technische Probleme in den Förderanlagen.
Kleine Korrektur, ich glaube Dänemark will nicht die ganze Meerenge blockieren,
sondern sie wollen russische Schiffe kontrollieren, ob sie denn Versicherungen haben.
Also von einer kompletten Blockade war meines Wissens noch nicht die Rede.
Ja ok, aber dann sozusagen Blockade für Schiffe, die keine westliche Versicherung haben.
Oder keine Versicherung haben, das weiß ich nicht.
Ja, also die andere Sache ist, dass China, das Russland hat man auch erwähnt,
weil der Embargo-Umgehung auch jetzt bei Importen ganz erfolgreich ist.
Sie hatten ja auch recht früh die Gesetze geändert, sodass Grau-Importe zulässig,
sind, die vorher verboten waren.
Da durften dann nur quasi die Konzerne oder die Inhaber der entsprechenden Markenrechte
dann auch entsprechende Waren neu vertreiben oder einführen und das wurde ja abgeschafft.
Und jetzt wird halt aus den Nachbarländern alles, was gebraucht wird.
Ja, grau importiert Und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass du auch jetzt die neuen
MacBooks oder so kriegst du jetzt auch in Russland oder das neue iPhone,
also fast zeitgleich mit,
wenn es hier auf dem Markt erscheint.
Und klar, teurer. Also es wird
natürlich teurer bezahlt, was halt auch entsprechend aufs Wachstum geht.
Und bei bestimmten Gütern ist es halt schwieriger oder problematisch,
weil die sich auf dem Wege nicht so leicht liefern lassen, wie jetzt,
spezialisiertes Equipment für Ölförderung, Software, bestimmte Chips,
bestimmte Metalle für den Raketenbau und, und, und, und.
Und da wird es dann komplizierter.
Plus haben wir ja gesehen, dass da jetzt zwei Verkehrsflugzeuge Notland müssen
aus technischen Gründen.
Und das eine steht immer noch auf dem Feld, übrigens habe ich gesehen,
haben sie einen Zaun drumherum gebaut, weil sie das gerade nicht wegkriegen,
die A23, die steht jetzt immer noch auf dem Acker und mit einem Zaun drumherum.
Das Schicksal könnte noch so einige Flugzeuge treffen, weil es ja generell von
Boeing und Airbus keinerlei Wartung mehr gibt und sie eigentlich alle Kisten
jetzt derzeit auf Verschleiß fahren und das wird sich auch irgendwann rächen.
Zusammengefasst, die wirtschaftliche Situation in Russland ist gemischt,
sicherlich nicht gut, aber von einem Zusammenbruch oder so ist im Moment auch nichts zu erkennen.
Gut, kommen wir zu einer anderen Debatte, die jetzt schon ein paar mal anklang
und die interessanterweise durch ein Paper,
eine Veröffentlichung, einen Text von Zaluschny, das ist der Chef der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte, ausgelöst wurde.
Es gab dazu dann auch ein Artikel, ich weiß nicht, war das New York Times oder
wo, da war ein Interview, glaube ich, nochmal mit ihm, wo er sich im Prinzip
zum Stand der Dinge in diesem Krieg geäußert hat.
Und das ist natürlich insofern etwas Bemerkenswertes, als dass jetzt,
sagen wir mal, der Chef der Armee mitten in einem Krieg, der normalerweise jetzt
nicht unbedingt viel Zeit damit verbringt für die Öffentlichkeit,
da ein Assessment zu machen, aber er hat es getan.
Und in diesem Text führt er im Prinzip auf, was wir hier eigentlich auch schon
diskutiert haben, nämlich wie die Situation ist an der Front und gibt auch offen zu,
dass derzeit dieser Krieg sich quasi so in einem Putt befindet.
Dass also beide Seiten nicht richtig vorankommen, dass es eben für die Ukraine
unter der derzeitigen Situation sehr schwierig ist, die russischen Verteidigungslinien zu durchbrechen.
Aber dass es genauso für die Russen unmöglich ist, ihre Offensive nennenswert auszubauen.
Wie wir ja auch jetzt gerade sehen, egal wie sehr sie sich anstrengen,
die Fortschritte sind also dann doch eher so im homöopathischen Bereich angesiedelt.
Nichtsdestotrotz auf beiden Seiten viel Leid, insbesondere natürlich bei der
Ukraine, die halt also weiterhin mit dieser ganzen Kriegssituation im eigenen Land leben muss.
Und damit verbunden war dann aber letztlich auch ein Aufruf zu weiterer Unterstützung,
also mit diesem klaren Bild.
Es ist halt oft so darüber berichtet worden, so ja hier, Ukraine gibt zu,
nichts geht mehr voran. Als ob das sozusagen in Stein gemeißelt wäre.
Tatsächlich war das aber eigentlich auch nur eine Diskussionsgrundlage,
auf der man dann eben nur argumentieren kann, Ja Leute, also wenn das so weitergeht
hier mit der Unterstützung, dann werden wir uns aus dieser Situation nie befreien können.
Und irgendwann gewinnt Russland, weil jede Verzögerung hilft eigentlich nur Russland.
Und das sollte sozusagen die Arbeitsgrundlage sein, um hier die politische Diskussion
weltweit in Gang zu kriegen.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass er diesen Text veröffentlicht hat,
ohne dass das mit Zelensky abgesprochen ist. Also das ist ganz klar.
Und von daher ist das eben ein Mosaik in der politischen Arbeit der Ukraine,
dass sie eben einfach klar macht, ihr müsst mehr tun, damit wir mehr tun können.
Das ist eigentlich, sagen wir
mal so. Denn eine Niederlage, also schon ein langsamer Sieg wird teuer.
Eine Niederlage wird noch teurer. Das ist halt noch die Geschichte.
Deswegen müssen diese Versorgungsprobleme mit Waffen, das muss ein Ende finden
und es ist hier weiterhin ein NATO-Engagement erforderlich.
Könnte vielleicht sogar so weit gehen, dass sich jetzt an der fehlgeschlagenen offensive,
also an der fehlgeschlagenen ukrainischen Offensive, zeigt,
dass die Verzögerungen dazu geführt haben, dass die Russen sich eingraben konnten,
dass man einfach zu lange gebraucht hat.
Hätte man jetzt vor einem Jahr die Mittel gehabt, als man nach der Kerson-Offensive,
und anderen, dass man dann einfach hätte weiter nachsetzen können,
sähe es anders aus.
Vielleicht weniger im Donbass, wo die Gegend befestigt war, aber jetzt im Süden,
da haben die Russen die Stellungen erst im letzten Jahr ausgebaut und sich da erst neu eingegraben.
Man hat ihnen einfach viel Zeit gegeben, das zu tun.
Was wir im Sommer gesehen haben, war Das war halt, glaube ich,
eine Konsequenz dessen, dass man zu lange gewartet hat, oder ja, im Westen.
Ja, definitiv. Also das war ein strategischer Fehler, hier so lange rumzurudern und nix zu tun.
Man hätte also wirklich sehr viel mehr bewirken können mit dem selben Geld,
was man jetzt sowieso ausgeben muss. Und so wird es halt weitergehen.
Also wenn wir weiterhin nur halbherzig das alles unterstützen,
dann drohen einfach weitere Verschärfungen und dann wird es halt noch teurer.
Das ist ein bisschen wie mit Klimakatastrophe.
Also wenn man da noch länger wartet, wird es jetzt auch nicht gerade billiger.
Das ganze geht so ein bisschen einher mit einer allgemeinen politischen Diskussion,
die immer wieder aus den extremeren politischen Zirkeln hervorquillt.
Man hat das in den USA, aber auch teilweise in Europa, so eben diese allgemeine
Forderung nach Waffenstillstand und Verhandlung. Das macht sich ja immer ganz gut.
So nach dem Motto, ach das mit diesem Krieg, das tut uns ja in den Ohren und
Augen weh, das mit anzusehen.
Hört doch mal auf damit, könnt ihr euch nicht irgendwie einigen,
macht doch mal einen Waffenstillstand, wir sehen dieselbe Debatte ja jetzt auch
gerade in Israel, auch wenn es da natürlich alles nochmal ein bisschen anders
gelagert ist, aber natürlich auch in der Ukraine.
Und ich glaube, diese Debatte müssen wir auch noch mal ganz kurz aufgreifen,
insbesondere vor einem historischen Kontext.
Also abgesehen davon, und das haben wir ja eben schon beleuchtet,
dass aus dieser militärischen Situation heraus derzeit ein Waffenstillstand
eigentlich nur den Russen nutzt.
Es ist halt auch einfach mal politisch überhaupt nicht zu vertreten,
einen solchen Waffenstillstand zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt zu fordern.
Insbesondere Verhandlungen und das
kann man glaube ich an mehreren Punkten festmachen, warum das sinnlos ist.
Das erste ist, Russland ist derzeit überhaupt nicht bereit zu irgendwelchen Verhandlungen.
Also das steht überhaupt gar nicht auf der Liste.
Selbst wenn es so wäre, wissen wir ja auch, wie Verhandlungen mit Russland laufen.
Weil es gab ja nun schon auch verschiedene ausgehandelte Friedensverträge oder
zumindest ein Waffenstillstandsabkommen. in den eingangs schon berichteten Minsker Verhandlungen etc.
All das, was in den letzten Jahren ausgehandelt wurde, in den letzten zehn Jahren,
war ja schon auf dem Tisch und darin stand, Russland greift die Ukraine nicht an.
Russland respektiert die Grenzen, die gesetzt sind und so weiter und so weiter
und so weiter. Und was ist passiert?
Russland hat genau das Gegenteil gemacht.
Ich denke, dass nichts, was bisher in diesem Krieg passiert ist,
dass es in irgendeiner Form eine Assurance geben würde, dass Russland sich an seine Verträge hält.
Okay, gut, man kann jetzt sagen,
das Frachterabkommen, das haben sie ja irgendwie halbwegs eingehalten.
Ja gut, aber das haben sie dann halt auch irgendwann wieder erkündigt und das war es dann auch.
Das ist halt einfach alles das Papier nicht wert, auf dem das dann unterzeichnet werden würde.
Und dementsprechend ist, glaube ich, die Forderung nach einem Waffenstillstand
von Politikern entweder nur damit zu erklären, dass sie diese Situation nicht
verstehen, oder noch schlimmer, dass sie in irgendeiner Form...
Ich will jetzt keine Unterstellungen machen, aber ich benenne ja auch niemanden,
aber ich habe also oft den Eindruck, dass sich hier Leute dann doch eher aus
anderen Kanälen finanzieren, als die, die man normalerweise für legitim erachten
würde. Ich weiß nicht, wie du das so siehst.
Die Russen sehen das natürlich ganz anders, Putin sieht das ganz anders.
Putin ist der Meinung, dass die Ukraine und der Westen den Vertrag von Minsk
gebrochen hat oder sich nicht daran gehalten hat und sieht das wohl sogar so,
dass letztlich der Vertrag von Minsk nur dazu gedient hat, dass der Westen die Ukraine aufrüstet,
um Zeit zu gewinnen.
Er fühlt sich quasi über den Tisch gezogen, dass Minsk nicht funktioniert hat und nur dazu diente.
Quasi für die Ukraine Zeit zu gewinnen, so ein bisschen die russische Sicht.
Die russischen Forderungen sind es letztlich, die einfach nicht funktionieren.
Russland möchte gerne die Krim und die anderen Gebiete haben, und zwar so,
dass auch international das Ganze anerkannt wird.
Das ist quasi das Ziel. Russland möchte gerne die besetzten Gebiete behalten
und dass die Ukraine dem zustimmt,
was natürlich auf absehbare Zeit nicht passieren wird.
Also, ja, oder wahrscheinlich nie so.
Und dementsprechend, ja, ist die Frage gut, wem würde das jetzt nützen?
Wahrscheinlich immer noch Russland im Moment.
Russland könnte sich gut leisten, die ganze Sache erstmal einzufrieren und aufzurüsten.
Also mehr noch als die Ukraine im Moment und könnte schön aus der Ferne, ja,
also Russland hatte ja jetzt in dem Sinne nicht die großen Kriegsschäden und
könnte da wahrscheinlich noch eine Weile weitermachen.
Ja, die Frage, die du ja immer wieder aufgeworfen hast,
warum ist die Unterstützung des Westens so stückweise?
Ich meine, wenn du überlegst, wo wir angefangen haben mit 5000 Helmen und so,
theoretisch hätte man die ganzen Sachen, also wo wir heute sind,
das Ganze hätte man wahrscheinlich auch schon vor zwei Jahren eintüten und vor
einem Jahr alles liefern können. theoretisch.
Also vielleicht nicht alles liefern können, weil teilweise Panzer und so weiter
muss ja auch erstmal bereitgestellt werden, aber die Entscheidung hätte sehr
viel früher fallen können.
Aber wenn man die Entscheidung gleich, ich sag mal, nach vier Wochen nach Kriegsausbruch
getroffen hätte, wo man gesehen hat, okay,
unsere Waffen werden jetzt dann nicht den Russen in die Hände fallen,
weil die die Ukraine überrennen, sondern die Ukraine hat dann eine reelle Chance.
Wenn man zu dem Zeitpunkt einfach den Hahn voll aufgedreht hätte,
wäre man jetzt viel, viel weiter.
Und die Frage ist jetzt, warum.
Und warum ist es immer noch so,
dass die Ukraine eigentlich nur so halb beliefert wird,
weil es gibt viele Waffensysteme, die sie ja nicht bekommen,
angefangen von den vorhin diskutierten deutschen Taurus und so,
und wie lange das dann mit den F-16 gedauert,
hat.
Plus bis hin zu, wie du auch erwähnt hast, dass viele der Waffen mit Lizenzbedingungen kommen,
die nicht gerade ideal sind, wie eben keine Ziele auf russischem Boden mit manchen
Waffensystemen anzugreifen.
Also teilweise kämpft die Ukraine einfach mit einer Hand auf dem Rücken und die Hand auf dem Rücken,
hat der Westen so ein bisschen festgebunden. Und ja, die große Frage ist, warum?
Und so ein paar Antworten habe ich jetzt in einem sehr ausführlichen Podcast-Interview.
Bei Lex Friedman mit John Mörsheimer verstanden, gehört.
Mörsheimer ist bei den Russen sehr beliebt, weil es einen Vertreter des defensiven
Realismus ist, was so viel bedeutet wie,
sehr kurz zusammengefasst, Realismus in dem Fall sagt,
unter Staaten herrscht Anarchie und im Zweifelsfall wird jedes Recht oder jede
rechtliche Vereinbarung oder jeder Vertrag, wenn man so will.
Spielt keine Rolle, sondern es gibt eben, ja, am Ende zählt,
sagen wir mal, das, was wirklich passiert.
Und Macht, Machtinteressen und Sicherheit geht halt über Recht.
So, das ist so ein bisschen die Sicht jetzt von Vertretern des Realismus.
Und sämtliche Argumente wie, naja, der hat aber jetzt, Russland hat aber angegriffen,
so zählen in diesem Denkmuster nicht,
sondern dort sind es dann, ich sag mal,
legitime oder nicht legitime, sondern einfach faktische Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands.
Ob sie legitim sind oder nicht, spielt da keine Rolle, sondern ja,
sie sind einfach vorhanden, sie sind in den Köpfen.
Und was Mörsheimer jetzt dort,
weshalb ich das sehr interessant fand, ist, dass Mörsheimer sehr schön dort
die russische Sicht auf die Dinge schildert, die nämlich eine Ehrsicht des,
Realismus ist.
Oder ganz klar, die Sicht des Realismus ist, dass so viel Macht über Recht geht
oder Sicherheit am Ende über alles geht.
Und bei der russischen Sicherheit spielt die Ukraine nur Rolle als Subjekt, als Objekt.
Sie hat jetzt keine eigenen Rechte, sondern ist halt nun mal Nachbar.
Man muss sagen, dass ja auch die USA mit ihrer Mondo-Doktrin jetzt auch keine,
feindlichen Bündnisse in der Nähe so richtig duldet.
Ich meine, gut, mit Kuba, da sind sie jetzt nicht einmarschiert, aber ansonsten, ja,
nimmt die USA durchaus auch in Anspruch, die sie jetzt nicht zugesteht,
das kann man jetzt auch sagen.
Nur auf der anderen Seite stehen sie halt Russland auch nicht zu,
so aus meiner Sicht, weil ja,
Russland eine ehemalige Supermacht auf dem Abstieg ist und insbesondere jetzt moralisch,
ideologisch, kulturell nichts zu bieten hat der Welt, was es sich lohnen würde zu übernehmen.
Also jetzt aus politischer Sicht. Sonst gibt es jetzt keine neue politische
Theorie oder kein Kulturbild,
was besonders attraktiv ist, weil sonst bräuchten sie diesen Krieg nicht zu
führen, sondern dann würden die Ukrainer begeistert auch Putin folgen und von
sich aus mit Russland mitziehen wollen.
Na, die Russen haben kein Hollywood.
Ja, unter anderem. Es ist einfach die Schaffens- oder Schöpfungskraft,
in Russland. Es ist einfach nicht so, dass es in die Welt hinausstreiten kann,
sondern im Wesentlichen mit Waffen und Gewalt und mit Geld und mit Rohstoffen.
Also sehr, ja, Korruption.
Er ist halt unter anderem ein Mittel dort.
Und um jetzt auf den Punkt zu kommen,
warum der Westen so zögerlich ist, ist, dass dort eine riesengroße Angst vor Eskalation herrscht.
Einmal die Eskalation, so eine softe Eskalation, dass Russland wirklich ernst macht.
Wie gesagt, wie man bisher gesehen hat, dass auch Putin Russland nicht voll auftritt,
wollte man deswegen auch nicht voll auftreten, weil man Angst hatte,
wenn man selber voll auftritt, dass dann auch Russland voll auftritt und dass
das Ganze dann noch schneller teurer wird.
Das ist sozusagen die kleine Angst.
Die große Angst aber ist, glaube ich, folgendes Szenario.
Also man liefert der Ukraine jetzt alles, was sie braucht,
um Russland zu vertreiben und zu demütigen und Russland quasi eine Niederlage zuzufügen.
Dass Russland dann in dem Moment tatsächlich zu einer nuklearen Demonstration greift.
Und das Problem mit so einer nuklearen Demonstration, warum das bisher auch
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg niemand gemacht hat, ist,
dass es eben komplett unerprobtes Territorium ist, weil ab dem Moment dann niemand weiß,
wie das weitergeht. In der Theorie.
Das hatten wir ja auch vor vielen Sendungen diskutiert, weil wenn Russland jetzt
Atomwaffen einsetzen würde.
Dass dann mögliche Antworten wären, also die Antwort wäre dann nicht nuklear,
sondern man würde dann direkt russische Truppen irgendwo auf der Welt oder in
der Ukraine angreifen aus dem Westen.
Aber in dem Moment hätte man dann bereits eine direkte Konfrontation zwischen atomaren Großmächten.
Und die hat man die letzten 60, 70 Jahre einfach komplett vermieden,
weil man einfach riesige Angst davor hat,
wie das dann weitergeht und ob man diesen Prozess dann irgendwie noch gestoppt kriegt.
Und diese Kombination, glaube ich, ist es, warum der Westen von sich aus nicht bereit ist,
so richtig den Hahn voll aufzudrehen, sondern man halt guckt.
Okay, ja, und deswegen glaube ich auch, dass die jetzt diese,
oder das russische Erfolge dann tatsächlich zur Folgen haben,
dass der Westen dann steigert, um zumindest zu verhindern, dass die Ukraine verliert.
Also ich glaube, da ist man fest entschlossen, zu verhindern,
dass die Ukraine verliert, aber gleichzeitig hat man Angst davor,
dass Russland richtig hart verliert, sondern fährt Und im Grunde genommen die Strategie,
das Ganze tatsächlich hinaus zu zögern und zu hoffen,
dass Russland irgendwann die Puste ausgeht und sie von sich aus auf die Idee
kommen, sich vielleicht zurückzuziehen.
Aber das wird halt natürlich auch nicht passieren.
Deswegen haben wir die jetzige Situation, wo die Ukraine unterstützt wird,
aber eben nur so stark unterstützt wird, dass sie nicht verliert,
aber nicht stark genug unterstützt wird, dass sie gewinnen kann.
Und diese Angst ist da, die wird nicht gerne ausgesprochen, also man hört wenige Regierungspolitiker,
weil das Ganze dann natürlich sofort missverstanden würde.
Und meine Frage ist, wie realistisch ist diese Angst?
Und da kann man jetzt verschiedener Meinung sein.
Einerseits sagen, Russland kann nicht wirklich eskalieren,
weil sie haben da schon jetzt alles reingeworfen, was sie reinwerfen können,
aber dem ist es tatsächlich nicht so, sondern es gibt schon noch ein reales
Eskalationspotenzial.
Nur der Westen hat sich jetzt auch durch die atomare Drohung nicht davon abhalten lassen,
die Schrauben immer weiter langsam anzudrehen, aber immer bedacht zu gucken,
keine zu großen Schritte zu machen.
Das ist mein Eindruck. Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass das auch so erstmal weitergehen wird.
Weiter liefern wird, weiter der Ukraine helfen wird, bis auf weiteres.
Aber das nicht damit zu rechnen ist, dass man jetzt nochmal,
dass der Westen hier richtig auftritt.
Also am ehesten, wenn wir vorstellen, dass Russland richtig auftritt und dann
erst der Westen nochmal wieder einen draufschlägt.
So nach dem Motto, die haben zuerst, die haben angefangen.
Naja, um einfach zu verhindern, dass die Ukraine verliert wird,
einem nichts anderes übrig bleibt.
Aber man will nicht von sich aus die Russland in die Situation bringen,
dass sie keine andere Wahl haben,
als voll zu mobilisieren oder gar, wenn das aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht,
klappt, dann, wie gesagt, trauen Putin dann auch zu,
eine kleine atomare Eskalation zu veranstalten, wenn er denn keine andere Möglichkeit hat.
Das Ganze, den Status quo aufrechtzuerhalten.
Und im Moment, ja, Status quo ist, Russland hat einen Haufen was,
15, 20 Prozent der Ukraine besetzt und muss das zwar jetzt verteidigen und viel
Geld ausgeben, um das zu halten, aber sie halten es im Moment noch.
Die Frage ist, was passiert, wenn sie komplett vertrieben werden.
Bisher war es so, alle roten Linien, die Russland gezogen hat,
sind früher oder später vom Westen oder der Ukraine überschritten worden.
Keine Kampfpanzer, keine Flugzeuge und Reaktionen sind ausgeblieben bisher.
Ja, weil Russland realistisch auch wahrscheinlich eingeschätzt hat, dass.
Dass das nicht ausreicht, um für die Ukraine zu gewinnen.
Und insofern, glaube ich, denken beide andere Dinge, als dass sie öffentlich
sagen. Das ist mein Eindruck.
Und sind im Grunde genommen gedanklich näher beieinander, als man denken würde,
was jetzt die realpolitische Situation angeht.
Also im Sinne dieses defensiven Realismus, die Supermacht Interessen über allem
steht, so nach dem Motto ja das ist alles total unangenehm da mit dem Krieg
und achja Menschenrechtsverletzung etc.
Völkerrechts, alles nicht so hübsch. aber die Gesamtbalance ist uns halt sozusagen
am wichtigsten, als dass wir jetzt hier für dieses Land das Richtige tun.
Mal so zynisch zusammengefasst.
Ja genau, Sicherheit vor Menschenrechten.
Ja,
das ist vielleicht was dran, obwohl ich ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten habe,
das aus so einer Perspektive zu betrachten, die ja im Prinzip so typisches Verschwörungsritual
ist mit, es gibt nur diese eine Sicht, die eine Gruppe hat, Sondern hier haben
wir ja schon eher so ein kollektives Ding,
wo so eine westliche Gesamtgesellschaft, die sich aus der EU alliierten und
natürlich den USA, Kanada, etc.
Zusammensetzt, dass die sozusagen kollektiv so einen Weg verfolgen.
Das muss ja eigentlich eher etwas sein, was aus einem Diskurs heraus entsteht. So würde ich das sehen.
Der große Punkt, denke ich, ist der Vormarsch des Rechts,
der globale Vormarsch des Rechts ist eine Bedrohung für die Regierung vieler
Länder, unter anderem auch für die russische Regierung.
Die russische auf jeden Fall, aber ist es auch eine Bedrohung für uns?
Ne, ne, wir sind ja diejenigen, die sozusagen zu der Seite gehören,
die internationales Recht propagieren und hochhalten und mit der EU quasi das Recht oder Regeln,
geschriebene Gesetze als Mechanismus zur Veränderung der Gesellschaft einsetzen,
während Russland und eher auf Mechanismen setzt wie Geld, Bestechung,
Gewalt, die wichtige Grundpfeiler des russischen Systems sind.
Aber nicht nur des russischen. Es ist nur, was meine Kritik an Mörsheimer oder
an dieser ganzen Theorie des defensiven Realismus ist.
Es mag so sein, dass dieser defensive Realismus bestimmte Dinge,
also einen Status quo, korrekt beschreibt.
Aber er lässt eben komplett außer Acht, wo man eigentlich hinkommen möchte,
nämlich ein internationales System zu haben,
was aus friedlichem Ausgleich und Handel und Mitteln der Konfliktlösung basiert,
die rechtsbasiert und sinnvoll ist und auf die man sich vorher geeinigt hat
und wo sich dann eben alle dran halten.
Nur haben wir so einen internationalen Mechanismus nicht.
Und ja, die Staaten sind, unter den Staaten herrscht Anarchie,
aber Ziel dieses Wissen, was der Westen tut, ist im Grunde genommen,
diese Anarchie unter den Staaten langfristig zu beseitigen.
Wenn man so will, Weltregierung ist jetzt nicht unbedingt das erklärte Endziel,
aber Darauf entwickelte sich nach und nach, internationale Institutionen zu
schaffen wie die International Court of Justice und die ganzen UN-Vertragswerke.
Das zielt darauf hin, die Mächtigen einzugrenzen und einzuschränken und das
Recht des Stärkeren abzuschaffen.
Aber es gibt eben Staaten wie
unter anderem Russland, die das als existenzielle Bedrohung betrachten.
Vermutlich alle autokratisch geführten Staaten betrachten das als Bedrohung,
wenn plötzlich sie sich an Menschenrechte halten müssen.
Das ist, glaube ich, der elementare Konflikt, um den es geht.
Und wo jetzt eben Mörsheimer quasi das komplett ausblendet,
wo man hin möchte und dass wir eigentlich weg wollen von diesem defensiven Realismus,
den er beschreibt als Zustandsbeschreibung der Welt und eigentlich auf dem Weg
sind weg davon und dass es jetzt gerade darum geht, dass dieser Weg in Gefahr
ist oder zurückgedreht wird.
Also ja, so sehe ich das Ganze.
Ja, ich mache mir natürlich auch weniger Sorgen darum, wie Welschheimer die
Welt sieht, sondern mehr so darum, wie unsere eigene Regierung die Welt sieht.
Und diese Zurückhaltung, die halt trotzdem noch drin ist, die vielleicht von
solchen Überlegungen ja auch geprägt sein kann, finde ich, muss halt trotzdem aufgegeben werden.
Das ist definitiv nichts, mit dem wir hier gesunden können.
Aber das ist the big struggle und dieser ganze Konflikt macht ein riesiges Fass
auf und es ist auch eine Situation,
in der man wieder mal die Welt in einem Gesamtkonflikt sieht,
nachdem man sich jahrzehntelang hat
so ein bisschen auf lokalere Auseinandersetzungen konzentrieren können.
Nachdem sozusagen der kalte Krieg überwunden war und diese ganzen Stellvertreterkriege
und sonstigen Fronten so ein
bisschen aus dem Sinn waren und jetzt stellt man auf einmal wieder fest,
das spielt trotzdem noch eine Rolle und wir haben das noch lange nicht überwunden.
Und jetzt sehen wir uns eben auch wieder mit diesen unmittelbaren Auswirkungen
dieser Machtspielchen konfrontiert und haben dann doch wieder Krieg in Europa.
Ich meine, die EU ist schön dafür gefeiert worden vom Nobelpreiskomitee,
wie viel Frieden sie doch in Europa gebracht hat nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Ich denke, hier ist man jetzt auch in der Pflicht, dann doch mal auch den nächsten Schritt zu gehen.
Und ich denke, das würde der EU sehr gut zu Gesicht stehen, das auch weiterhin
anzustreben und dann eben auch zu erreichen.
Und das eben mit allen Mitteln, die dafür erforderlich sind.
Dazu gehört sicherlich auch erst mal die Überwindung des Widerstandes von Ungarn,
weil es geht meiner Meinung nach einfach mal überhaupt nicht.
Und da muss man sich, glaube ich, nochmal ganz schön neu aufstellen.
Aber dann eben vor allem auch in der konkreten Unterstützung der Ukraine.
Wir müssen jetzt ein Ende finden, weil wir hier schon seit fast drei Stunden am diskutieren sind.
Ja, wir sind auch am Ende.
Ich denke nämlich auch, dass wir jetzt eigentlich erstmal alles gesagt haben,
was uns zu diesem Zeitpunkt...
Ich hatte ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen die Erwartung, dass es ein kurzeres
Update wird, aber es ist einfach so viel drin in dieser Situation und ich glaube
ganz gut, dass wir das auch mal so dargelegt haben. Ich hoffe nächstes Mal wieder
mit noch besseren Meldungen.
Wie immer, wir legen uns das Thema beiseite, wir beobachten die Situation so
gut wir es eben können und sammeln ein und kommen dann wieder zu euch und fassen die Gesamtsituation,
zusammen so wie sie sich uns darstellt mit den Betrachtungen, die wir machen.
Und ich hoffe, dass wir nicht in 18 Jahren noch immer über den Ukraine-Konflikt,
berichten müssen, aber ausgeschlossen wäre es nicht.
Wieder deine Vorhersagen.
Du weißt doch, so ein Podcast immer on the high note. Naja, das kriegt ihr auch nochmal hin.
Leute, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, das war's von uns, von UKW und wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Macht's gut, ciao.